Here's
the basic shape of church history. Just
to wrap our minds around the big
picture, getting the aerial view of what
took place. If you really want to
contemplate what unfolded in the history
of the church, something like this.
First of all, there was the formation
period. This is what we call apostolic
Christianity. This is where Jesus
has initiated or set in motion a
beautiful picture of God that gives rise
to a particular kind of church called
the New Testament church. New Testament
Christianity, the apostolic church.
These are those people in Acts chapter 2
who have all things common and there's
nobody who is in want among them. These
are people whose hearts are overflowing
with other centered self-giving love for
one another because they have gotten a
picture of the other centered
self-giving love of Jesus giving his
life at Calvary.
But then what happened? There was what
the prophets foretold to be a
deformationation
period in church history.
This was warned about in scripture as
we're going to see in a moment. But the
deformationation wasn't merely, listen,
it wasn't merely a deformationation
of practice or ceremony.
What was taking place about the 3rd and
fourth century after the apostolic
period? What was taking place is that a
deformed, a distorted picture of God was
being palmed off on the people, on the
masses as though it were the truth. And
gradually, as the decades went by,
people began to believe
dark things about God that were foreign
to the love that was manifested in
Christ. And then down through long dark
ages,
there came a point
at which reformation was necessary and
inevitable. People were beginning to
stand up in their liberty and pay
attention to what was going on inside
their hearts and minds. They were
beginning to push back on the ugliness
that was being palmed off on the people
in the name of Jesus. And if it wasn't
Luther,
it would have been somebody else. What
I'm going to suggest to you is that the
reformation is a process and it
continues to this very day. And that you
and I have the privilege, the awesome
privilege of continuing the reformation
started by Luther. And that's why in the
shape of church history, what is
depicted here is that reformation is
going to continue until it produces a
complete restoration
of the apostolic faith. And you and I
have the privilege
by God's grace of being part of that
continuing reformation.
Hey there. As always, welcome, welcome,
welcome. Especially if this is your
first time being with us. Always want to
give a warm welcome to those of you that
are new Adventist or otherwise.
I want to take a minute to before we get
into things here to thank our partners,
those of you who have donated to our
efforts. It is your generosity that
allows for scaling and growth to happen
at a more rapid pace leading to reaching
more Adventists with the truth. We share
testimonies on YouTube on Fridays and
throughout the week on Instagram. Uh I
want our partners to know that you are
playing a key role in the lives and
souls of real people, real families all
around the world. So that should be
encouraging to you. Just want to again
thank you for your support. It really is
a team effort. Now, I wanted to start
with that short clip because it speaks
to what we will be looking at in depth
tonight. That was SDA Pastor Ty Gibson,
who we looked at a couple weeks ago.
What he said explains one of the uh
foundational starting points of the SDA
church's claim regarding history.
That's right. Tonight, we're going to be
getting into uh not just theology, but
history. This will be another instance
of getting to see how the great
controversy is the fundamental starting
point and everything else flows
downstream from that especially history.
The claim being that there was apostolic
Christianity then a great apostasy
leading to a reformation some400
1500 years later that then birthed a
restoration.
the SDA church supposedly being the
fruit of all of that history as the
fullness of apostolic Christianity was
being restored and the central thing in
focus being the character of God getting
distorted and then now it's being
vindicated and restored by the SDA
movement which we heard it there in that
clip but uh when we looked at Ty Gibson
a few weeks ago we heard that same sort
of thing. What's actually ironic about
this is that the SDA church is a part of
the great apostasy not the restoration
and remedy coming out of it. They are
just one of the many parts of the true
great falling away from the true Christ
and his gospel. That's the leading
people after after a false Christ and a
false gospel. Some of which we will get
into this evening. But we're not going
to use Ty Gibson to help us out this
week. To help us out tonight, we're
going to take a look at another portion
of a sales pitch that uh SDA Church
President Ted Wilson gave a few years
ago. We looked at it in part previously.
It was titled Why So many denominations?
Why so many denominations? If you recall
last time we listened to the first half
or so of this, we looked at Revelation 6
and that it supposedly teaches, it's
just a plain thus sayeth the Lord that
denominations were foretold as a tool of
Satan to deceive people. Um, you won't
be out of the loop tonight if you
haven't seen that, but if you want to
see it, the link to that is in the
description box down below, so you can
check that out later if you would like.
But we are at uh the part of his pitch
where he transitions into discussing
history, particularly different figures
in history. And what we're going to be
paying particular attention to and doing
some analysis on um are the ways in
which history is told within Adventism.
What people uh may not realize,
especially if you're not a former
Adventist, is that what we're going to
be listening to is simply Ted Wilson
pariting the great controversy chapter
by chapter. He is simply giving a
cliffnotes which if for those that do
not know the book the great controversy
is a historical fiction.
Let me repeat myself. It is a historical
fiction. It is history told from a
specific angle built on a faulty
foundation to then try and write the SDA
church into the story like te like Ty
Gibson did there. That is not to say
there's no truth there, but we will get
into uh well that's exactly what we're
doing tonight is looking at how uh truth
is always mixed with error. Deception is
never just typically 100% deception.
Last week though, we looked at an
excellent example of how uh this sort of
reading Adventism into the Bible makes
itself seen where we looked at an
Adventist apologist who made the wild
claim that the book of Daniel is all
about Seventh Day Adventism. Uh not just
that, the whole Bible everywhere.
Genesis, the fall, all of it points to
uh the end times people and seventh day
adventism, etc. So, uh we're going to
see a similar vein of thinking tonight,
but that's going to be applied in this
case to history. All of history is just
leading to 7th day Adventism. That's
what all of history is about, including
church history. Uh the claim is that
throughout history, God was raising up
certain figures to eventually restore
the fullness of apostolic Christianity
in an end times group from every tribe,
tongue, people, and nation. that last
day people obviously being the SDAs. To
get there, they have to fashion a chain
through history that allows them to then
attach themselves at the end as the
final link. So, we're going to examine
this chain, and we're going to see how
structurally sound each link is. We will
be doing some historical and theological
blacksmithing, if you will. This will
help further demonstrate why I'm
constantly telling you all that if you
want to understand Seventh Day
Adventism, folks, and engage with
Adventists, which is what our hope on
this platform is, not that you just get
a bunch of head knowledge,
hopefully you're entertained, hopefully
you get knowledge, hopefully it's
beneficial, hopefully it's educational,
but we really want you to put it to use.
And if you're going to if you're going
to do that, you're going to have to
start by understanding the great
controversy theme, the Adventist
worldview. It is that that puts them
outside of the bounds of Christianity.
They have a foreign totally different
worldview than Christians. It's not
coming from scripture. It's coming from
Ellen White essentially who claimed that
it came from God. But I also want us to
look at how in Adventism the gospel is
defined as the SDA system of theology.
It is not the person and work of Jesus
and his vicarious death on the cross for
the forgiveness of sins. They have added
their entire system of doctrines to this
and then call that whole system the
gospel. Just like the Judaizers in
Galatia, they've added all sorts of
stuff to the gospel resulting in a false
gospel. Remember friends, the Judaizers
believed in the death, burial, and
resurrection of Christ. But they added
to the message that one must be
circumcised to come to Christ. They
added circumcision to the gospel. Do the
scriptures talk about circumcision? Yes.
Doesn't make it the gospel.
Circumcision was not simply a belief
they held. They added it to the gospel
message which distorted the gospel and
resulted in a false gospel. The Holy
Spirit says through the Apostle Paul
that is cursed by God. So it's not that
the Bible doesn't speak to doctrines
outside of the person and work of
Christ. It obviously does. But that
doesn't make them the gospel. That's the
problem. Labeling your entire system of
theology as the gospel. Scripture says
the gospel is the power of God for
salvation. What one believes for the
forgiveness of sins. One doesn't have to
believe the SDA system of theology to
receive the forgiveness of sins. So, we
have quite a bit to look at. This is
going to be one of those longer
examinations. We get comments all the
time from people 3 hours, four hours.
Yep, we do long form, mid form, short
form. We do it all. And stuff like this
is necessary, folks. So, let's get
comfortable and let's get back into our
friend Ted Wilson here. The church
hierarchy was substituted
actually for God himself in many cases
and they substituted the son's day
for the Sabbath.
Human dogmas replaced the clear
teachings of God's word. For centuries,
God's truth was cast down to the earth.
Would God's truth be trotten down
forever?
Would the light of truth ever shine
again? Would God's word ever be the
foundation of the church again? Well,
listen to this. The book of Jude. It's a
very small book, a powerful book. And in
verse three, there's only one chapter in
Jude. It's very very close to the very
end of the New Testament. Beloved, while
I was very diligent to write to you
concerning our common salvation, I found
it necessary to write to you, exhorting
you, instructing you, helping you to
understand,
to contend earnestly,
to to guard, to protect, to to to
work for
the faith which was once
for all delivered to the saints.
So this inspired writer indicates to us
that the light of truth would shine once
again.
Okay. So for context, remember the title
of this presentation is why so many
denominations.
He started the talk by saying that
Revelation 6 supposedly teaches
denominations are a tool of Satan to
confuse people. He's continuing now to
build on this answer and is essentially
adding the details to what Ty Gibson was
getting at in that little intro about
this uh deformationation
into this total apostasy.
Ted has now transitioned to making a
number of claims regarding doctrinal
accretions that crept into the church
over time and needed addressed where
he's going to try and put forth that God
raised up various individuals to address
one specific thing with the SDA movement
being the accumulation of all of these
individual correct points from these
various people into one system as God's
final last day people with total
doctrinal perfection. That's the pitch.
And I say pitch because this is a part
of one of their week-long evangelistic
series where they're trying to win
people to Adventism and basically pitch
you on the whole schema. So he's taking
a partial truth here that there were
doctrinal accretions that crept into the
church over time, which is what the
things on the slide behind him are in
reference to, but then underneath those
titles, he's going to slip in things
from Ellen White and the Great
Controversy. And this is where the
blurring of the lines between truth
happens and people get taken for a ride.
For example, were there issues
surrounding church hierarchy? That was
one of the things listed on there. Sure.
But what is it that he slipped
underneath that heading?
The church substituted the sun's day for
the Sabbath,
Ted. No, it didn't. No, it didn't. And
what he means here is that the pope
changed the Sabbath. So, this is taking
a general truth that tr that church
hierarchy needed reform. That's what you
get uh the magisterial reformers.
They're sometimes called that
generation. But then they insert
something under that that's not correct.
Now, we've looked at this I don't know
how many times and debunked it. But
since I have an agreement with myself to
silence this lie every time it's
asserted on principle, we have to open
this can of worms yet again. Again, if
you're going to engage with SDAs, you
need to just add this to the arsenal.
You need to have this one memorized. You
are going to hear this ad nauseium. They
are going to parrot this over and over
and over and over and over.
Adventists that are honest and actually
care about facts, please listen. Okay.
The SDA church loves to site 18th
century church historian Dr. Philip
Schoff and rightly so. Schoff was an
excellent historian. Not just saying
that because he was a Presbyterian. He
was. Even Roman Catholic scholarship
lauds him oftentimes. What does he say
in his history of the Christian church
on this subject? We have looked at this
before. What does he say?
Quote,
"The observance of Sunday originated in
the time of the apostles
and ever since forms the basis of public
worship with its enobling, sanctifying,
and cheering influences in all Christian
lands." Close quote.
And let's not forget from his book
titled The Origin and Growth of Sunday
Observance in the Christian Church, SDA
pioneer JHW Wagner said this quote, "Dr.
Schoff is justly esteemed as a man of
extensive learning and whose testimony
regarding facts no one would call in
question. He is a theologian and a warm
friend of Sundayeping." Yeah, Schoff was
a first day sabotarian, but his
theological relations have not prevented
his giving the facts into the first
Sunday law.
Close quote. Well, Mr. Wagner Schoff
states emphatically that the new
covenant day of worship was established
with the apostles.
Nothing to do with Constantine, the
papacy, the council of Leodysia, or any
of the other conspiracies the SDA church
has tried to prop up to bolster their
conspiracy. And we looked at at before
at how Wagner quote mines Shaw on this
specific subject to his own detriment to
try and make it appear as though Sha
supports this first Sunday law that he's
putting forth aka Constantine's edict of
Milan. Except Scha totally refutes this
silly uh conspiracy by saying people
place way too much into this edict that
simply legalized Christianity. It didn't
change anything other than protecting
Christians.
However, what Ted is appealing to is
what Ellen asserted.
Notice, quote, "I saw that God had not
changed the Sabbath, for he never
changes, but the Pope had changed it
from the seventh to the first day of the
week, for he was to change times and
laws." Close quote.
So, God supposedly showed Ellen that the
Pope changed the Sabbath from Saturday
to Sunday. That's where this is coming
from. Adventists will then proof text
Daniel 7:25 till they're blue in the
face, but it doesn't make the claim
biblical. It is coming from Ellen White,
not scripture.
This is just the verse they try to point
to like Ellen did at the tail end there
to try and say, "No, see, it's strictly
from scripture." Nope, that's your
interpretation.
That is your interpretation.
It does not say that in the text
and we are going to highlight that
indefinitely moving forward. It is your
interpretation. The text does not say
that,
not even indirectly.
And it doesn't say it because this is
total fiction.
God didn't show this to Ellen White. All
of history refutes this. The same Ted
Wilson that tells us the only approved
hermeneutic in the SDA church is the
historical grammatical method. Well,
Ted, all of history refutes you guys on
this, as Shaw rightly pointed out. It
goes back to the apostles, not the pope.
I got a challenge for you. Get your best
scholars from the Adventist Biblical
Research Institute to come on to
Answering Adventism and bring your best
textual exe.
I don't care who it is. Have them walk
us through the text using the HGM and
show us that you'll arrive at the
conclusion that the Pope changed the
Sabbath is what the text is saying.
Because the HGM involves understanding
how the text would have been understood
by the original audience.
the audience it was pinned to
and you examine that by the grammar of
the text which is why historical
grammatical then you make valid present-
day application after that so let's hear
it they can have as much time as they
need I'll give you three hours if you
need open call to the best biblical exed
of the SDA church we want to see this
because I have yet to see it and I've
listened to I don't know how many of
your pastors read I don't know how many
of your papers from SDA scholars and not
a one of them utilized the HGM and
walked through the text verse by verse
to demonstrate the claim. They all
parrot your guys's Bible commentary
which is Ellen White. Her comments on
the text you guys believe are
infallible. Therefore, that's the
correct interpretation. So, it must just
be a plain thus sayeth the Lord.
Christian, when you hear Adventists
appeal to this claim that the Pope
changed the Sabbath, expect to hear the
onslaught of outofcontext Roman Catholic
sources, such as Steven King's
catechism, where they appeal to
statements where Rome claims Sunday is a
mark of the Roman Catholic Church's
authority. Adventists appeal to these to
try and say, "See, they even admit it.
The Pope changed the Sabbath." But no,
that isn't at all what they are saying.
They believe the apostles were the first
Roman Catholics. So when they say the
church in this context, they mean the
apostles.
They assert that Protestants have no
basis for worship on Sunday because it's
apostolic in origin. You'll notice all
these statements that they post to are
or or point to are postreformation
statements and they're said in response
to Protestants. So Rome claims that if
the apostles were the first Roman
Catholics and Protestants broke away
from Rome, then it logically follows
that they don't go back to the apostles
and have no basis for the apostolic
institution of worship on Sunday. That's
the argument.
It is in the context of apostolic
succession and what it means to go back
to the apostles because all sides all
sides Protestants, Catholics, Orthodox,
etc. all agree it's apostolic in origin.
Just like Sha said, the SDA church
cannot deal with the fact that both the
Eastern and Western churches are
branches of the church have always
corporately worshiped on the first day.
Only someone ignorant of the Eastern
branch of the church would make such a
silly claim like Ellen White did. But
like I said, we've already buried this
claim multiple times, so you can go
check that out for a more thorough deep
dive. The point being Ted's presentation
here is demonstrating that more of their
foundation is built on faulty premises
because remember his pitch here is how
the SDA church is the fullness of
apostolic Christianity restored. There
was a great apostasy in the first
century and then the truth was gradually
brought back to light after descending
down the stairs on the slide behind Ted.
And all of these assertions along the
way are necessary elements for the
narrative to work.
Now, we're going to get into his claim
of the Bible being the foundation for
the church momentarily, but he mentioned
Jude. The faith once for all delivered
to the saints. Yeah, that's not
Adventism, Ted. And to try and put forth
that Adventism is apostolic Christianity
restored is almost hard to even take
seriously. You mean to tell me that a
bunch of anti-trinitarian gospel
heretics in the 19th century that
bounced from one false cult to the next
were apparently the one that the triune
God they were the ones that the triune
God used to restore his church.
That's what we're supposed to believe.
The triune God used people that didn't
even believe in him to restore his
church.
And they weren't even just
christoologgical heretics, folks. They
were numological heretics, too. They had
a false Holy Spirit, which Paul warns
about in 2 Corinthians 11. But God
apparently used a bunch of heretics that
resurrected ancient heresy to restore
the truth of the Christian faith, just
like he used Joseph Smith and Charles
Russell and every other heretic of the
19th century that claimed the same
thing. But notice the Advent Review and
Sabbath Herald, as it's now known as the
Reviewing Herald, May 5, 1932, official
organ of the SDA church, folks. This is
their church paper.
Quote, "The very fact that this prophecy
of the three angels messages, Revelation
14, covers the period between 1844 and
the end of this age shows concl show
shows conclusively that this three-fold
message is God's special message for us
at this very hour.
Just as surely as we are living between
18:44 and the coming of Christ, just so
surely may we know that this three-fold
message of Revelation 14 6-12 is God's
present truth for this present time. The
time for this message is very
definitively fixed to the present
generation.
He who will receive this prophecy as
given by Jesus Christ may be just as
sure that this is Christ's special
message for us today. And if Jesus were
to appear in person and speak this
three-fold proclamation with an audible
voice,
in harmony with this idea that this
message is limited to the period between
1844 and the end, we find that no one
prior to 1844 had ever claimed to have
given this three-fold message. Neither
Luther nor Calvin, nor Knox, Wesley,
Alexander, Campbell, or any other of the
great lights of those times set up the
claim that they were doing the predicted
work of Revelation 14:6-12. If this work
had been done by any of them, they would
have surely known it.
This prophecy of Revelation 14 6-14 does
not and cannot
does not and cannot refer to any
proclamation of the gospel in the days
of the apostles,
the early church fathers or the
reformers of the 16th, 17th or 18th
centuries.
It is strictly a last day message
applicable to those who live just before
the return of Christ.
Ted, why does your organization's own
source documents state that your guys's
message doesn't go back to the apostles?
It wasn't preached by the apostles, but
it's the faith once for all delivered to
the to to the saints that Jude is
referring to.
Jude is not referring to your guys'
present truth special only for you guys
end times message. That's not the faith
once for all delivered to the saints.
Because what Jude refers to as being
preached by the apostles
is what the apostles were preaching. The
apostles weren't preaching the
investigative judgment for the
forgiveness of sins, young earth
creationism for the forgiveness of sins,
or any of what you guys label the
gospel.
That's what they mean by the word gospel
though, folks. The SDA system of
theology. And because we know we're
going to get SDAs that want to say
something to the effect of, "Well,
that's only one source." Here you go.
And we could do this all night. I've got
article after article after article.
Same publication, Review and Herald,
November 29, 1934. Quote, "This movement
with which we are connected stands for
certain great fundamental truths.
the existence of God, the inspiration of
the Holy Scriptures, salvation alone
through the vicarious sacrifice of the
Lord Jesus, repentance, regeneration,
and the gift of righteousness by faith,
the work of the Holy Spirit, the
immutability of God's law, the binding
claims of the Bible Sabbath, the
priestly ministry of Christ in the
heavenly sanctuary, the investigative
judgment now going on, the soon coming
of Christ to take his children home, the
doctrine of spiritual gifts, the
manifestation of the gift of prophecy in
the remnant church, life only in Christ,
Christian temperance, and other leading
important certain Bible doctrines. These
great truths constitute the everlasting
gospel message for this time. Close
quote. All of that is what the SDA
church calls the gospel.
Believing in imminency is the gospel.
Believing imminency is the power of God
to salvation. The forgiveness of sins
comes by believing imminency.
If you don't believe that Christ could
come could come at any moment, but you
do believe he's returning. No, you're
you don't have the gospel. That's false
gospel.
They use the term gospel to apply to
their whole system, but it's not
systematic theology. And all the buzz
phrases in there like righteousness by
faith are like always terms that they
use that were being used by the
reformers and have a certain
understanding by Protestants. But then
they redefine them. don't tell you that
to try and say we believe just like you,
brother. See, see, but Ted,
this is the restoration of apostolic
Christianity and what Jude has in mind.
How when at the same time you guys claim
you have a special present truth message
that only you guys have and it doesn't
go back to anyone else, including the
apostles.
Now, let's look at Jude and notice
something else the Holy Spirit tells us
that's rather interesting.
Okay.
Jude 3-5.
He says, quote,
"Beloved, although I was very eager to
write to you about our common salvation,
I found it necessary to write appealing
to you to contend for the faith that was
once for all delivered to the saints.
For certain people have crept in
unnoticed who long ago were designated
for this condemnation. ungodly people
who pervert the grace of our God into
sensuality and deny our only master and
lord Jesus Christ. Now I want to remind
you although you once fully knew it that
Jesus who saved a people out of the land
of Egypt afterward destroyed those who
did not believe and thus the reading of
God's holy word. So the faith once for
all delivered to the saints was being
attacked in the first century by people
who crept in unawares and perverted the
faith by what?
Denying the Lord Jesus Christ.
You can't plug any figure into the name
Jesus that you want. You have to have
the right Jesus. That's step one. Which
is why Jude then goes on to describe the
true Christ that's in focus and explains
his deeds in history. What is the first
one that he appeals to?
Jesus leading the Israelites out of
Egypt. Ah, interesting. Why is that?
Because what does Deuteronomy 5 tell us
regarding who led Israel out of Egypt?
Deuteronomy 5:15.
You shall remember that you were a slave
in the land of Egypt, and the Lord your
God brought you out from there with a
mighty hand and an outstretched arm.
Therefore, the Lord your God commanded
you to keep the Sabbath day. Thus the
reading of God's holy word.
So who did it? The most high God did it.
The almighty Yahweh. That's what the
term Lord there is in reference to which
means what?
Jesus is Yahweh. The almighty God. Sorry
anti-rinitarians, especially those
within Adventism. Checkmate.
All glory to the triune God. May he
crush the idol of Adventism under his
feet as a foottool. And how ironic that
it's the second giving of the law and
the fourth commandment where SDAs will
never reference in the Sabbath
discussion. They only ever cite Exodus
20:8. Well, Exodus 20 says nothing about
redemption from Egypt. Deuteronomy says
nothing about creation. Israel was to
remember creation, but then in the
second giving it switches to redemption,
or rather the addition of redemption is
added to be also remembered, which means
what, Ted?
That's a change in the law. And Jesus is
the one that did it because he gave it.
So I guess now Daniel 7 is about him
changing God's law, right?
But furthermore, Ted, Jude is warning us
about people like your prophetus who
said that the man Christ Jesus is not
the Lord God Almighty, that he was
exalted to be made equal with the father
prior to the creation of the earth. How
was Yahweh exalted to be made equal with
Yahweh?
The Adventist Jesus isn't even
omnipresent. We've looked at I don't
know how many of the christoologgical
heresies that Ellen White claimed
regarding the SDA Jesus. So, in a sense,
you're correct. You guys are in focus in
Jude, but not in the verse that you want
to be. You guys are a part of what Jude
is warning us to be on the lookout for.
Those who have crept in unawares and are
leading people after a different Jesus
and a different gospel. But also, what
Ted claims Jude 3 says isn't what Jude
said. Did you catch his restorationist
spin the very last statement there?
Jude didn't write anything about the
light of truth shining once again
such that it went out or that the true
faith disappeared for all for you know
for a period and needed restored. Yes,
there have been dark periods of history
post tentibbrus lux but the flame never
went out and needed to be reit. The
faith that was given to the apostles by
Christ did not disappear and need
restored. But the SDA church must have
this be the case for this entire
framework to work.
They don't like to consider themselves a
part of the restorationist movement, but
they are.
Many of the SDA pioneers were coming out
of Unitarian Restorationist cults such
as the Christian Connection. And that
mentality bled over not just into
Millerism, but 7th Day Adventism. But
it's not true. The gospel was never
entirely lost and then needed to be
restored.
The reformers were not restorationists.
A reformation is a buttoning up of
what's already present. It's not gone.
It's a change to something that's
already present. A restoration is a
reviving of something that's gone or
lost. This did not happen with the
Christian church. Yet, that's what they
have going on here. All restorationist
proponents are always individuals that
have no connection to the church in
history. The reformers were Roman
Catholics, not restorationists. They
weren't rogue people bouncing around in
fringe fanatic movements that up and
deemed their day to now just be the end
times and they're God's chosen people
because they prayed real hard and God
told them, which is exactly what the SDA
pioneers did. And to try and say that
they're continuing the Reformation
leading to or or that continuing the
Reformation leads to a restoration is
what's called conflation. They can
appeal to Ellen White growing up at the
Methodist church as a kid and try and
weasle themselves in. But no, they were
all a bunch of leoty associated with
fringe heretical sex. So to compare them
to the reformers is shameful. Now he's
going to begin laying out ultimately
what Ellen White claims God showed her
in the great controversy vision,
beginning with the Waldenzians. Pay very
close attention. God would raise up
courageous men and women who would be
faithful to his holy word. One of these
groups was named the Waldensians.
They were bible-belving Christians who
lived in northern Italy
on the western side of Italy and in
southern France. In fact, my wife and I
have had the privilege, maybe some of
you have, of visiting that very region,
Tora Pelletche, in the mountains of
Italy. The popular church despised these
godly believers. They were brutally
persecuted and they fled into the
mountains of the Alps. And there in
hidden Waldensian villages and settings,
Bible truth flourished.
Some of the remnants of those villages
are even present today. You can go and
see them.
This is where men and women who stood
faithful to God's word lived long ago.
They said, "Our mind is held captive to
the word of God."
So, there's a secret Bible school where
the Waldensian young people studied
God's word. I've been there. It's It's a
sobering place.
They made copies of the word of God.
Then they were sent out to different
countries in Europe and cities as
students or peddlers, people who would
be selling things. And as they found
opportunity, they would leave these
precious little fragments of the word of
God with someone they perceived
was truly interested in Bible truth. The
Waldensians restored the truth of the
Bible and the Bible alone.
They restored that truth that God's word
and God's word alone must be obeyed.
And God began to raise up a variety of
men and women.
Okay. So, Uncle Ted is back to his old
tricks. He's regurgitating Ellen White
here. For anyone that's read the great
controversy, this was basically just a
flyover of chapter 4 titled the
Waldenzians. But he says the Waldenzians
were Bible believing Christians.
Then what's the big deal if one affirms
what the Waldenzians do in the present
day? After all, the Waldenzians are
still around.
But Adventist theology proper dams a
Waldenzian to predition if they hear the
SDA message and reject it as being
incorrect because of scripture. The only
thing Ted will credit them for is that
they apparently stood firm on scripture
being the only infallible rule of faith
and practice. That's not all the
Waldenzians stood for, Ted, or even all
that they're known for. So why do you
guys cherrypick this one thing? Or why
did Ellen rather? Because it let you
rewrite history. That's why. We're going
to circle back to the Waldenzians in a
bit after he says something else. It'll
give us the answer to uh why a
modern-day Waldenzian is damned uh
according to Adventism. But to test his
claim that Adventists believe like the
Waldenzians regarding the Bible, Ted,
the Waldenzians believe the Bible is the
only infallible rule of faith and
practice for the church. Only
infallible.
You guys don't. You have two supposed
infallible sources. The Bible and Ellen
White's writings, which are an
infallible interpreter of the Bible, as
we have demonstrated and shown verbatim
many times. So, no, not even the single
thing that you want to cherrypick. Do
you guys agree with the Waldenzians? So
the first link in the chain is broken.
This will become more evident shortly.
There was Yan Hus or John Hus in Prague
in what is now the Czech Republic. He
was a Catholic priest. He began to study
the word of God. And as he studied, he
declared, "Obedience to God is my motto,
not obedience to man."
As a result,
Yan Hus
was burned at the stake. He was a
courageous hero whose life was dedicated
to obeying God. In fact, it is told
that he died in the flames
singing
glory to God.
My dear friends here this morning,
I believe with the Waldensians that the
Bible and the Bible alone is our guide
to truth, not the traditions of the
church. And I believe with John Hus or
Young Hus that obedience to God is our
only motto. What do you say,
Ted? This is still a very watered down
representation. And no, you don't agree
with the Waldenzian's position on the
word of God. And it's great that you
like a statement that Yon Hus made, but
how does that prove this overarching
narrative that that was the one thing he
contributed in this long chain of
contributors that you guys will be the
final link in? Y'all, Yan Hus was was
seeking to reform the priesthood.
He wanted to the word of God to be
available in the language of the leoty,
for example. Yet, we heard nothing about
that because that's not what's in focus
here. The focus here is carefully
crafted a a carefully crafted retelling
of history with the SDA movement being
the central character. Cherry-picking
out one thing that they like to then try
and link themselves to these
individuals. The Husites became the
Moravian church. They believed in
obeying the gospel, the same gospel that
Lutheran believe, Presbyterians believe,
Baptists believe, etc.
You have to have the correct gospel to
be able to obey it. And the SDA church
does not. Also, Ted, the husites were
monist, not synergist, which we're going
to get uh look at in this next section
more fully. So, again, the Hussite chain
link damaged at least.
God raised up another Catholic priest,
a mighty man of God in faith,
Martin Luther.
As Martin Luther struggled with issues
of faith, he visited Rome.
Many of you may have been to Rome. You
may have made a visit to Rome. In fact,
you may have seen some of these amazing
sites. When Martin Luther visited Rome,
he sensed that guilt was crushing out
his life. And in an attempt to find
peace, he did many penances. You know,
we just talked about penences, trying to
do something to win favor with God,
including climbing the famed Pilot's
staircase
on his knees.
He thought if I can climb these stairs
Jesus supposedly climbed when he
approached Pilate.
And I say supposedly because
that's Rome and the stairs were not in
Rome. Jesus wasn't in Rome. So anyway,
we would just say supposedly
he says I'll find peace.
But when Luther returned home, he still
felt this
opposition, this this horrid oppression
of guilt.
All of his pilgrimages and his penences,
everything he tried to do hadn't taken
away the feeling of unworthiness.
Then
fortunately, Martin Luther could read
the Bible. In those days, Bibles were
chained to the walls. In those days,
most people could not read the Bible.
Many of you at home today have several
Bibles in your home.
How often do you read them?
Go to your Bible every day.
Let the Bible change your life. But
Martin Luther could read the Bible. He
went to the Bible and he read in Romans
1:17,
"The just shall live by faith."
Not by penences, not by climbing stairs
on your knees, not by flagagill, self-
flagagillation, beating yourself. No.
Now in Acts 4:12
we read, "There is no other name under
heaven given among men by which we must
be saved." So he saw Jesus a new as a
mighty savior. Luther was dumbfounded.
He was amazed and he experienced a new
peace in his own personal life.
I want to tell you as I stand here on
this platform here in Indianapolis,
I believe with Martin Luther that
salvation comes not by the works of our
own hand, not because of what we have
done, but it comes because what Jesus
did on the cross for us. Amen. I believe
that salvation only comes
by the grace of God.
Ted, it doesn't matter that you think
Adventists affirm Luther's understanding
of grace when you guys affirm a
different gospel than Luther.
Luther didn't believe the investigative
judgment was the power of God to
salvation or the health message or the
spirit of prophecy in Ellen White's
writings or the other novelties that you
guys affirm and call the gospel. He
said, "Like Luther, I don't believe
salvation is by the works of my own
hands, not by what we have done, but by
uh what Jesus did on the cross for us."
Ted, I'm sorry, but yet again, this is
just Christian ease.
You guys don't realize that Lutheran,
including Martin Luther, are monists.
You can't divorce this from Luther's
understanding of grace. So, first notice
SDA historian George Knight. What does
he say? This is from his Andrews
University Seminary studies volume 51.
Quote, it's a bit of a long quote here
folks, but bear with me. Arminius and
John Wesley identify that special
infusion of grace as prevenient grace.
Provenient grace in its many facets is
that convicting calling, enlightening
and enabling grace that is provided
before conversion and makes repentance
faith and the freed exercise of the will
possible.
Remember that line.
Without prevenient grace, even accepting
God's offer of salvation by faith would
be both a human work and an
impossibility for fallen humans. Thus,
prevenient grace, so to speak, is the
work of the Holy Spirit to wake up those
dead in sins and to prepare them for the
acceptance of saving grace. In other
words, prevenient grace unbinds the will
so that it can make a choice for God.
Catch that.
The mention of other forms of grace and
cooperation brings us to a topic that
has been divisive in the extreme between
Calvinists and Armenians, but one
crucial inso in sotiology. While both
groups agree that salvation is by grace
alone, received by faith alone, they
differ as to human participation. The
theological divide runs along the line
of monism versus synergism. Monergism is
the belief that God is the sole agent in
salvation and that human beings have
absolutely no part in cooperating with
God in their salvation. Calvinism with
God predestinating everything by his
sovereign will. That's actually uh not
entirely correct there, folks.
Predestination has to do with salvation,
not the decrees of God. but nevertheless
takes the position of monergism.
Synergism by way of contrast is any
belief that salvation is a cooperative
project and process in which God is the
superior partner and the human person
being saved is the inferior but
nevertheless crucial partner. Close
quote.
Lutheran are not Arminians, folks.
They're not Calvinists either. And John
Wesley did not understand grace the same
way that Luther did. Lutheran are
monergists, not synergists. and they
don't believe in prevenient grace. And
this is the heart of the matter because
when Luther talked about grace and grace
alone, this was said in the context of
monarchism.
George Knight talked about monism as a
distinctly Calvinist thing over and
against Armenianism when no Lutheran are
neither. And yet they're monists because
all branches of the reformation were
monists which is what Luther said the
central hinge of the reformation swung
on.
This is why I was telling you guys
earlier remember what George Knight says
here about the unbinding of the will.
Notice Martin Luther bondage of the
will.
Luther's first work in snowballing
outside of the thesis, I guess, and his
and his h highleberg disputation. This
is from his debate back and forth with
Desidarius Arasmus. It is in written
format.
Quote,
"It is not irreligious, curious, or
superolous, but essentially wholesome
and necessary for a Christian to know
whether or not the will does anything in
those things which pertain unto
salvation." That's sotiology.
Nay, let me tell you this is the very
hinge upon which our discussion turns.
It's the very heart of our subject. For
our object is this to inquire what free
will can do in what it is passive and
how it stands with reference to the
grace of God.
Ah
ah you guys believe like Luther did
regarding grace alone, Ted? No you
don't. You guys are synergists on
steroids, not monists. You are on the
irrassmian side of the debate over the
bondage of the will, not with Luther.
Which is why it's almost comical that
they want to claim to be heirs of the
reformation. They disdain monarchism. I
can't tell you how many SDA pastors I've
talked to about this and they loathe
monism. They hate it.
The central hinge of the reformation was
monism over and against synergism. And
if you don't understand grace in the
context of that, you're not heirs of
Luther's view regarding grace. What he
means is they've cherrypicked
Christianes language in this case the
word grace and grace alone. And then
they don't actually get into what that
really means. Adventists affirm
prevenient grace. All branches of the
reformation reject this. Doesn't matter
if it was Calvin in Geneva in France,
Luther and Meenan in Germany, uh Thomas
Kramer and and the English reformers,
William Perkins, the Italian reformers,
Geralamozi, Nicholas Bound, it's like
literally none of them, none affirmed
what Adventists do in this regard. On
top of all of this, Ted Luther is
arguably most known for the law gospel
distinction, something that you guys
outright reject. That is another
universal tenant of the Reformation.
We've looked at this, I don't know how
many times, but you also can't
understand Luther's understanding of
grace apart from this other central
aspect of the Reformation. Notice from
one of Luther's sermons,
quote, "Everything that that proclaims
something about our sin and God's wrath
is the proclamation of the law,
however and whenever it may take place."
On the other hand, the gospel is the
kind of proclamation that points to and
bestows nothing else than grace and
forgiveness in Christ.
Ah, that word grace again.
Now notice Lewis Burkoff. We've looked
at this before
from his systematic theology. He
explains this in more detail. quote,
"The churches of the Reformation from
the very beginning distinguished between
the law and the gospel as the two parts
of the word of God as a means of grace."
This distinction was not understood to
be identical with that between the Old
and New Testament, but was regarded as a
distinction that applies to both
testaments. There is law and gospel in
the Old Testament, and there is law and
gospel in the New. The law comprises
everything in scripture which is a
revelation of God's will in the form of
command or prohibition. While the gospel
embraces everything, whether it be in
the Old Testament or in the News
of
that proclaims the seeking and redeeming
love of God in Christ Jesus. Close
quote.
The law gospel distinction is an
interpretation principle.
How one should handle the Bible. The
Bible has two parts really. Both parts
are a means of grace. Which is why the
whole Bible is for the Christian. All of
it. Law is anything in the older new
testaments that comprises commands or
prohibitions. Do not do this, do not do
that. Gospel is anything pertaining to
grace, mercy, redemption, forgiveness,
etc. Adventists don't affirm the law
gospel distinction or the word and
sacraments as a means of grace. They
believe that the law is the gospel and
that grace frees a person to keep the
law and that through your cooperation
with the heavenly trio and the
prevenient grace that they'll give you,
you can begin to keep the law and
eventually get to a point where you do
so perfectly silencing Satan's
accusations in the great controversy,
demonstrating that you're safe to save.
Because that's what it all comes back to
in Adventism, silencing Satan in the
great controversy. But now notice John
Otto, professor uh Wisconsin Lutheran
Seminary
from his blog. Quote, "For true
Lutheran, the proclamation of the word
and the administration of the sacraments
is at the heart of the Christians life
and the church's work because the means
of grace is how the spirit changes
hearts." Close quote.
Ah so Lutheran like all branches of the
reformation another universal believe
the word and sacraments are the means by
which God monogistically draws people to
himself and the way by which the spirit
changes hearts.
What Ted means when he says it's by
grace alone is that without God giving
you some prevenient grace, you wouldn't
be able to come at all. But that
prevenient grace doesn't actually result
in an effective end.
The cooperation of the sinner in doing
their part in meeting the conditions of
salvation is required wherein the sinner
and God cooperate together to eventually
bring about salvation. So God can't save
someone until man does something to
enable God to be able to be a savior.
Here is Ted's prophetus demonstrating
this
quote. Will man take hold of divine
power and with determination and
perseverance resist Satan as Christ has
given him example in his conflict with
the foe in the wilderness of temptation.
God cannot save man against his will
from the power of Satan's artififices.
Man must work with his human power aided
by the divine power of Christ to resist
and to conquer at any cost to himself.
In short, man must overcome as Christ
overcame. And then through the victory
that is his privilege to gain by the all
powerful name of Jesus, he may become an
heir of God and joint heir with Jesus
Christ. This could not be the case if
Christ alone did all the overcoming.
Man must do his part. He must be victor
on his own account through the strength
and grace that Christ gives him. Man
must be a co-orker with Christ in the
labor of overcoming and then he will be
partaker with Christ in his glory. Close
quote.
God cannot save man against his will.
She says, "Okay, thank you for admitting
that you are not on the side of Luther
in the Reformation and have zero
business claiming to be chained to him
in any fashion."
This is precisely the hinge of the
Reformation. The bondage of the will. Is
man's will enslaved such that until God
as the first cause frees it, he will
remain in the hostile status to God? Is
God free to free the will of his own
valition? Or does he need some sort of
cooperative effort from man before he's
able to do so? Ellen says it's a
synergistic work.
That is not what Luther believed.
And what does she say about grace? It's
pervenient.
It's an enabling force that gives you
the strength to now do your part and be
a co-orker with Christ in overcoming all
sin in obedience to the law of God,
which will then bring one favor with God
and you'll be saved.
This is precisely the SDA plan of
salvation that Ellen lays out from the
chapter titled the plan of salvation
spirit of prophecy volume one. Quote,
long one here folks.
Sorrow filled heaven as it was realized
that man was lost and the world that God
created was to be filled with mortals
doomed to misery, sickness and death,
and there was no way of escape for the
offender. The whole family of Adam must
die. I saw the lovely Jesus and beheld
an expression of sympathy and sorrow
upon his countenance. Soon I saw him
approach the exceeding bright light
which enshrouded the father. Said my
accompanying angel, he's in close
converse with his father. The anxiety of
the angels seemed to be intense while
Jesus was communing with his father.
Three times he was shut in by the
glorious light about the father. And the
third time he came from the father, his
person could be seen.
His countenance was calm, free from all
perplexity and trouble, and shown with
benevolence and loveliness, such as
words cannot express. He then made known
to the angelic host that a way of escape
had been made for lost man. He told them
that he had been pleading with his
father and had offered to give his life
a ransom and take the sentence of death
upon himself. That through him man might
find pardon that through the merits of
his blood and obedience to the law of
God, they could have the favor of God
and be brought into the beautiful garden
and eat of the fruit of the tree of
life. Close quote.
So despite the division within the
Adventist heavenly trio here, the father
having to be convinced of a plan
proposed by Jesus as a apparently an
afterthought,
this is antithetical to the law gospel
distinction, which is why every Lutheran
heard this and their head just exploded.
Some Adventists love to say, "No, no, we
don't believe our works merit salvation.
It's only Jesus's merits." But notice
the above. Notice the quote. It's
Jesus's merits plus what?
your obedience to the law. That's what
gets you favor with God. This is a false
gospel.
And no, it doesn't mean that you're
therefore advocating for carnal living.
That's just the false dilemma fallacy.
He tried knocking Rome earlier regarding
penance and saying Rome claims something
you do earns God's favor. Yet again, SDA
double standards abound.
Your doings in this system, your
obedience to the law plus Jesus's merits
get you favor with God. It doesn't
matter that they say their works don't
have merit. Salvation comes about by God
and your actions. That's not Christ
alone. That's not what Luther was was
saying. It's not what any of the
reformers were saying. But because all
Adventist rivers flow down from the
great controversy theme, this is
necessary because in order to silence
Satan's accusations that the law can't
be kept perfectly, man has to
demonstrate that yes, you can. God's
grace will then enable you, give you an
upgrade to do so. And then you do your
part with Jesus's assistance to get you
to a point of keeping the law perfectly
to silence Satan. This then vindicates
God's character and the law, which is
the central focus of the great
controversy, God having to vindicate his
character from one of his creatures, the
devil. And we could look at quote after
quote after quote, where she very
plainly demonstrates Ellen did not
understand the law gospel distinction,
which is why the SDA church needs to
stop claiming that they are an heir of
the Reformation and that they apparently
agree with Martin Luther on grace alone.
Not even close. So once again, another
link in this chain is badly broken. You
don't affirm grace like Luther nor grace
alone the way that Luther did. You
reject the law gospel distinction. You
don't uphold the means of grace through
the sacraments and the word. You're not
monist and a number of other things. So
if you guys are heirs of the
reformation, you've apparently reformed
so far that you look nothing like the
reformers,
which makes perfect sense because
restoration and reformation are not the
same and are antithetical to one
another. He also completely ignored that
the Moravian Hussites, Lutherans, and
Waldenzians, the three that we've looked
at so far, they were all united on the
gospel.
Still are to this day. They all affirm
the law gospel distinction and that the
gospel is the good news of the person
and work of Jesus, the apostles creed.
It's like Christianity 101, man. They
all affirm the true Christ. total unity
on the foundations of the Christian
faith because the triune God is who is
in the apostles creed was just in the H
Highleberg catechism with my family
earlier doing our family worship we were
literally on the question regarding uh
this the creed and the stanzas broken up
into the three sections for father son
and spirit
they all were agreed on the fundamentals
their differences and and disagreements
are not gospel issues their theological
mechanics and complexity ities that get
into the finer theological details. So
folks, I hope you're seeing how theology
is interconnected and you can't do this
sort of plucking style approach that
that Ted and Ellen are trying to pitch.
Well, you can, but you'll be an
inconsistent mess like Adventism is.
See, the light of truth would penetrate
the darkness
just as it took 500
years for the church to go from the
white horse of pure apostolic faith to
the pale horse of spiritual deadness. It
took time for God's faithful followers
to grasp glimpses of truth lost sight of
down through the ages. God would not
switch on a light and have truth come
down on our minds all at once.
It took time.
God gradually began to restore Bible
truth in the 1300s and the 1400s with
the Waldensian people with John Hus with
Martin Luther each bringing a particular
understanding adding to the collective
pure truth of God to the people of God.
Do you know now why there are so many
denominations?
Because the Waldensians
stopped where they were. They said the
Bible and the Bible only is truth. But
they didn't keep studying the doctrines
of the Bible. Let me tell you, my dear
friends, the doctrines of the Bible,
that sounds so formal. That sounds kind
of official. Let me tell you, every
single doctrine of the church and of the
Bible according to the Bible is based on
the beautiful connection with Jesus
Christ.
God began to restore Bible truth and the
Waldenzians stopped where they were. No,
Ted, this is the great controversy that
is saying this, not real history.
You're cherrypicking people and making
these assertions.
One of which is that the Waldenzians
didn't care about doctrine. They stopped
where they were. Folks, I'm going to try
and remain calm here. This particularly
irks me, this specific topic.
Ted, I would love to know your basis for
this assertion because that is quite the
statement. Tell me you don't know
anything about the Waldenzians without
telling me you don't know anything about
the Waldenzians.
Once again, we have this movement trying
to ride the coattales of people like my
spiritual ancestors. But if you believe
like they do in the present day, you'll
be lost because God supposedly gave more
light since then. That's what he's
getting at here, folks. The Waldenzians
care deeply about doctrine
deeply.
And I say care, present tense, because
they're still around.
They're not some old relic of history.
Ted talks about them the way Ellen did
as some relic of the past back there
somewhere. Folks, they're still around.
It's like, it's so rude to talk about
people like that. Like, it'd be like
talking about a Baptist as if they're
some ancient whatever. And it's like,
well, no, I can go talk to a Baptist.
It's just so rude to do that.
The Waldenzian churches are reformed.
They align themselves with the
Presbyterian churches, Ted.
And in Latin, they were called the
mother of the reformation, which is why
I'm sure Ellen tried appealing to them
and started there. It's because they
were around before the Middle Ages. But
in 1559, we have an article on this, by
the way, on the website
answeringadaptism.com. Just type in
Waldenzians in the search bar up top.
It'll pop up. But in 1559, they adopted
the Hugenot Confession of Faith called
Dea Rochelle.
Then in 1655 they formulated their own
confession which was drafted in Italian
immediately after their massacre which
is now historically known as the
Pedmont's Easter which is why there's
not that many of them around today. They
were massacred.
They weren't just massacred because they
believed the the the Bible was the
foundation Ted. They were massacred
because of their doctrine.
This was a shortened version in the in
Italian of the 1559 Hugenat confession
which confirms that their theology
aligns with Presbyterian Calvinism.
This is still the basis of the
Waldenzian faith today and pastors in
their church have to agree to uphold it.
If they stopped where they were, why'
they go to formulate uh confessions and
statements of faith? Ted.
Ted, the Waldenzians care very much
about doctrine, and shame on you for
claiming that they don't or didn't. They
have a doctrinally rich history. But
that throws off your whole script.
What Ted really means is that the
theology of the Waldenzians looks
nothing like Adventist theology. So,
they have to milk them for what they can
to then just cast him to the wayside.
Sorry, but this caricatururing of the
Waldenzians really irks me.
These are my spiritual ancestors.
Nothing about the Waldenzians helps
Adventism. Nothing.
And to claim that they didn't care about
doctrine is simply a lie. It's a lie.
And to talk about them as as though
they're some extinct people of the past
when there are Waldenzian still in Italy
and Argentina today is just insulting.
News flash, Ted. They don't agree with
your caricatururing of them.
And I think they can speak for
themselves better than your prophetist
who used them as cannon fodder to write
herself into the story. I get it. You
guys don't see it that way. But that but
it is what it is.
Again, it'd be like talking about
Baptist as though there aren't Baptists
around. Not just that, but then claiming
things about Baptists that aren't true,
not realizing people could go to a
Baptist to verify the claim.
In the great controversy, Ellen White
tried to claim that the Waldenzians were
seventh day sabotarians,
which is why you'll find Adventists
often claiming this.
Oh, the Waldenzians carried the Sabbath
torch before we did and and we we
carried that truth along that they
carried all the way back to the
apostles, the seventh day Sabbath.
Sorry, this is just flatout not true.
The Waldenzians are first day
sabotarians, Adventists. First day. And
Ellen White was too ill-informed to
realize that when she when they used the
term Sabbath, they didn't mean seventh
day or what SDAs believe about the
Sabbath, just on a different day.
This is why she then botches this big
time in the great controversy, further
evidencing this wasn't coming from God.
It's why the White Estate has since had
to add this comment to the appendix of
the chapter, trying to correct her
ridiculous error. Notice folks,
this is from the appendix in the book
from the fourth chapter on the
Waldenzians. Look at this
quote. The heading for it is the Sabbath
among the Waldenzians.
There are writers who have maintained
that the W the Waldenzians made a
general practice of observing the
seventh day Sabbath. This concept arose
from sources which in the original Latin
described the Waldenzes as keeping the
dasis dominical or Lord's day Sunday but
in which through a practice which dates
from the reformation the word for Sunday
has been translated Sabbath but there is
historical evidence of some observance
of the 7th day Sabbath among the
Waldenzes. A report of an inquisition
before whom were brought some Waldenzes
of Moravia in the middle of the 15th
century declares that among the
Waldenzas, not a few indeed celebrate
the Sabbath with the Jews, according to
Johan Joseph Ignes von Dolinger.
There can be no question that this
source indicates the observance of the
seventh day Sabbath.
So instead of just recognizing the
historical flub, they say, "Well, they
didn't keep they did keep Sunday as the
Sabbath, but but but Johan von Dolinger
documents how they checks notes
celebrated with some Jews at some point,
and that proves without question they
were seventh day sabotarians."
Never mind their actual confession of
faith, which states that they are first
day sabotarians.
We're going to hijack their history and
tradition and try and ride their
coattails to ride our write ourselves
into the story. Talk about shameful. The
white estate ought to be ashamed of
themselves.
And I would tell them that to their
face, too. These Adventists want to say,
"Oh, you're just tough online." No, I
would tell this to Merlin's face. I
would say, "Shame on you. Shame on your
organization."
You can read the Hugenot Confession. The
Waldenzians are proudly Presbyterian,
and God bless them.
Sorry, but this irks me. Liars. You're
liars.
You guys don't care about the truth. You
care about your tradition.
Oh, but we don't have any tradition.
Yeah, says the person that's a slave to
tradition.
It's so rude and dismissive and totally
insults the rich theological history of
the Waldenzians.
And the Waldenzians were greatly
indebted to the likes of people like St.
Francis of Aisi who Ellen White doesn't
even mention because he was too Roman
Catholic for her.
St. Francis sought to reform the
church's decadence in accordance with
the life of Jesus found in scripture. He
felt as though the church had become uh
too extravagant which led to him living
a life of abject poverty and
selflessness trying to lead by example
and reform the church. Went on to found
the uh the Franciscan friars, the
Franciscan order.
Why isn't he in this chain of reformers
Ted? Oh, right. Because you can't
cherrypick him to serve the SDA church.
The point being, this is not actual
history, folks. Study actual church
history. The great controversy ain't it.
Well,
the Hussites said obedience to God, but
they didn't keep going. The Lutheran
said salvation by faith. Martin Luther
has it all. But they didn't keep going.
God raised up these good and these great
men of God who had partial light, but
not one of them had complete light.
Ah, the Anabaptist hand.
And this is why you guys need to stop
claiming to be heirs of the reformation
for the eenth time. You guys are more in
line with the radical reformers, the
Anabaptists.
The fact that Ellen White tried
inserting the Anabaptists as reformers
in this long chain is almost comical.
The Anabaptists were a
counterreformation movement. Folks,
this is exactly what their battlecry
with with Luther and Calvin was. You
guys didn't go far enough.
Yeah. which then you look at them, it's
like, "Yeah, you guys went so far,
you're you just completely demolished
the whole thing."
But they serve the case for a historical
group that affirms what Adventists do
about baptism. So, they'll try and milk
them as well along the way. More on the
Anabaptists in a moment. God raised up
another man, John Calvin, in Geneva,
Switzerland.
Calvin emphasized the importance of
Christian discipline and growth in
grace. His followers became known as
Presbyterians.
Once again, a church is built around the
teachings of a man God raised up. What
each group failed to recognize, and this
is an important point for you to
consider
was that God was using different church
leaders to restore varying aspects of
Bible truth.
Ah, John Calvin, the man notoriously
known for his robust theology around
predestination, heavily influenced by
the works of St. Augustine and
Augustine's commentary on on uh Romans 5
in particular, is cherrypicked to say he
got his understanding of growth right.
Just like the most gen growth, that's
what you're going to cherrypick. Okay.
Yeah, because that's what Calvin's
really known for, right? Growth. He
said, "Calvin emphasized Christian
discipline and growth and grace." Ted,
Calvin did not understand grace the way
you guys do.
Again, like I like you tried doing with
Luther. These men were monarchists, sir.
Not synergists. Their understanding of
grace is downstream from that. But the
great controversy just ignores all of
these inconvenient facts. So Ted does
too, which further evidences that Ellen
White had no clue what she was talking
about. He said, "What each group failed
to realize was that God raised up
various church leaders to restore
various aspects of Bible truth. Ted, you
started this sales pitch in the first
part that we looked at by claiming that
you guys only believe a plain thus
sayeth the Lord as you held up your
Bible, which we heard you repeat over
and over and over." Sir, I've read my
Bible cover to cover a number of times.
Where did I miss the uh chain of
doctrines that you're cherry-picking as
God raising up individuals to have one
piece of truth that is then going to end
in a cornucopia of a movement that has
all those cherrypicked things? Where
does it say God raised up John Calvin,
for example, to restore the truth of
growth? It doesn't.
What they'll do is they'll point to a
prophecy somewhere and insert this into
the text because Ellen claimed it and
you guys believe she's divinely inspired
and she's the infallible interpreter.
That's what's actually going on here
because you are arbitrarily latching on
to one thing from various individuals
claiming this is what God showed Ellen
White and then saying you guys are at
the end of this chain as the fullness of
the truth restored. And since Ellen said
it and you think God was speaking
through her in your mind it is a plain
thus sayith the Lord. Nope. Sorry. Not
going to cut it.
John Calvin gros I mean seriously.
So the institutes of the Christian
religion Calvin's magnum corpus work can
be distilled down to growth.
It's like the most generic thing
possible. Ellen would have been better
off not even trying to mix Calvin into
the cake batter because reformed
theology folks is not a friend of
Adventism. I can assure you that.
But he said Presbyterianism is built
around the teachings of a man that God
raised up.
Except no, this is where we get more
assertions that can't be backed up. It's
like when people say Calvinism means you
believe whatever John Calvin taught. No,
that's not what that means. The term
Calvinist was a later and anacronistic
term applied to the Genevan and French
Reformation due to Calvin's influence.
But what's rich about this is that this
is coming from a movement that's built
around a woman.
Ted, listen to GI Butler. Your
conference president ancestor further up
the chain from you.
Quote, "Our position on the testimonies,
that's the writings of Ellen White, is
like the keystone to the arch. Take that
out and there's no logical stopping
place till all the special truths of the
message are gone. Our enemies and the
master they serve realize this. But some
of our people are so blind that they do
not.
Ah so all the special truths of
Adventism which is supposed to be this
fullness of the truth that Ted's
referring to are dependent upon Ellen
White's writings. Just as the keystone
of the St. Louis arch is held up by the
entire the entire structure is held up
by the keystone. So Ellen White's
writings uphold all these special
truths.
And if you're an Adventist and you don't
see it, you're blind.
She's supposedly the infallible
interpreter, Ted. You can't even
understand the Bible, according to you
guys, without the lesser light to light
your path in understanding the Bible.
I'm a Presbyterian, yet I disagree with
John Calvin on all sorts of things. I've
read a lot of John Calvin. He's with us
tonight, actually, by the way, folks.
He's right there.
One also, the thing that's ironic about
this, one also doesn't have to take a
vow to John Calvin's writings to be
baptized in the Presbyterian church like
you do with Ellen White in the SDA
movement.
Here's how the SDA baptismal vows,
folks, regarding Ellen White have
changed over the years.
Notice in 1874,
do you recognize that the remnant has
the spirit of prophecy and that this has
been manifested to this church through
the writings of Ellen G. White
1932? Do you believe the Bible doctrine
of spiritual gifts in the church? And do
you believe in the gift of the spirit of
prophecy which has been manifested in
the remnant church through the ministry
of and writings of Mrs. Ellen uh of Mrs.
EG White? And then in 2000, do you
accept the biblical teaching of the
spiritual gifts and believe that the
gift of prophecy is one of the
identifying marks of the remnant church?
The Bible knows no concept of taking
vows at your baptism, let alone vows to
believe and uphold a false prophet.
We're also not stuck, Ted, having to
claim all of John Calvin's writings are
divinely inspired and correcting of
inaccurate interpretations of scripture
like you guys claim about Ellen White,
which further evidences that because
Adventists have inherited Ellen White's
ignorance, they don't understand
denominationalism and what denominations
are. So, let's maybe tone down the
accusation that all of us are the ones
built around a single individual.
John Calvin holds zero authority over me
as a Presbyterian, sir. zero.
Many Adventists will try and say the
same thing regarding Ellen. Then you
point out something heretical that Ellen
White said and instead of denouncing it,
all of a sudden they're defending her.
There are numerous things you can show
me that Calvin said and I'll say, "Yep,
he's wrong. It's over." Yeah, he's
wrong. He was wrong. Didn't know what
the heck he was talking about. He didn't
know what the heck he was talking about
with Michael the Archangel. He was
wrong.
But also the Presbyterian tradition,
specifically the Church of Scotland,
has a robust history long before John
Calvin. Folks,
he didn't even mention John Knox, but
the Church of Scotland traces its roots
back to the sixth century with St.
Columba, who was a missionary that
converted Scotland to Christianity
starting in Iona
and really even before that
because St. Ninian in the 4th century
made the first Christian converts in
Scotland. Columba converted the country.
Yes. Long before the 1500s. St. Columba
linking back to John the Apostle.
What took place in the 16th century was
the beginnings of Presbyterianism as a
movement.
Our heritage meaning Presbyterians is
Catholic and ancient
and it doesn't revolve around John
Calvin. The Westminster standards govern
Presbyterian churches, not the writings
of John Calvin. The Westminster Assembly
was made up of over 120 theologians of
English Parliament. And the standards
are subordinate to scripture.
They're a statement that says this is
the system that we believe is accurate
to the to what the Bible teaches as a
system. We also don't have our own
gospel. You can add John Calvin to the
list of all the individuals that Ted has
mentioned so far. And unlike the SDA
church, we all affirm the same Christ,
the same gospel. That's the foundation
of Christianity. What does Paul tell us
in Philippians 1, for example?
Only let your manner of life be worthy
of the gospel of Christ. So that whether
I come and see you or I'm absent, I may
hear of you, that you are standing firm
in one spirit with one mind, striving
side by side for the faith of the gospel
and not frightened by anything in your
opponents. This is a clear sign to them
of their destruction, but of your
salvation and that from God. and thus
the reading of God's holy word.
Paul's desire for the church was to be
united in one mind on the gospel and the
true God, striving and contending for
that foundation. That's the faith once
for all delivered by to the to the
saints that Jude's talking about, Ted.
Which is why the same Paul in Romans 14
says that some doctrines are disputable
matters.
Disputable matters.
Unity in essentials, liberty in
non-essentials.
But this is also why Adventist
apologists are terrified to debate and
contend for their false gospel publicly
because it's a sign of their
destruction. And we who have the true
gospel are not frightened by their paper
tiger theology.
They'll tell you that. That's what they
want you to believe. Oh, you're scared.
Oh, yeah. I'm just shaking in my boots
of your false ancient heresy gospel.
What all this actually shows, Ted, is
that we're the ones that are united. And
it's the SDA church that's divided into
a mess of cherrypicking various ideas,
redefining them in light of the great
controversy, resulting in a totally
novel sect of history now just claiming
to be God's true church with a bunch of
special insight that no one else has.
The SDA church isn't even united on who
God is and what the gospel is. You have
entire riffs, folks, within the SDA
church. We're going to be looking at
this next week.
burial service again. We buried Ellen
White some months ago. Now we're going
to be burying the rest of the SDA
pioneers and rearing Ellen White
on this exact subject because you guys
have entire riffs within your movement
due to the SDA pioneers who are Aryan
and semi-aran heretics. They don't know
if they're worshiping three beings or
one being. Most of them are functional
tritheists.
They can't agree on the gospel. The
evangelicalesque types want to try and
agree with Christians. The old path SDAs
think it's the SDA church's special
message and so on and on and on. All of
that to say Ted has no clue what he's
talking about because Ellen didn't and
he's simply paritting her homework.
The majority of the great controversy,
folks, focuses on the SDAs. These
figures in history are only mentioned to
be a self-serving stepping stone for the
SDA cause to try and chain and tether
themselves in history and not look like
a 19th century novelty.
All of the groups mentioned so far have
their own rich histories that don't
agree with this silly caricature.
Lutheran have a rich theological history
and a robust theology
as do Presbyterians as do the
Waldenzians and the Moravians which is
the Hussites.
Yet, if you affirm one of these
theologies today, like myself, you're
damned according to this movement.
That's what's so ironic about all this.
Ellen latched on to these individuals
from history, gives them credit for one
single thing that Adventists will agree
with on the surface because again, they
redefine things, and then discards them
to the trash heap of history
as it pertains to the chain link of
growth and grace. Again, Ted, you
evidence you don't know what Calvin
taught about that. Calvin was a
monarchist like Luther. Calvin affirmed
the word and sacraments as a means of
grace by which God alone transforms a
person, making them more holy.
meaning
which I don't want to get off on this
because I love this topic and it's very
easy for me to get distracted but for
example
we take the Eucharist weekly because it
actually does something believe it or
not something happens uh I don't know
when you partake of Christ and you
consume Christ
you guys don't teach that you don't
believe that
both of the folks that you've mentioned
grace on Ted believe in the presence of
Christ in Eucharist it's like one of
primary means of grace.
Yet you guys are chained on to them
because of grace.
No.
Now Calvin disagreed with Luther
regarding whether that grace could be
resisted.
But both agreed that God alone does this
work by the means of word and
sacraments.
You can't just take a phrase growth and
grace and then plug in whatever you want
to try and claim you're now aligned with
someone.
What does that person mean by the
phrase? Ted wants to make it seem it's
like this real remedial. The SDU church
believes in growing in holiness. So
therefore, we share something with John
Calvin. So now we chain back to the
Presbyterians or have a historical, you
know, that's how we can have a an actual
flag back in history. Does not work that
way, sir. Calvin believed that growth in
holiness was the fruit of God working
through the means of grace
monogistically, the word and sacraments.
You guys don't believe this. You guys do
communion like four times a year and you
don't believe in real presence that
Christ is actually present in Eucharist.
Calvin did. Again, his his understanding
differed from Lutheran's mechanically
regarding physical or spiritual
presence. But we fundamentally agree
that Christ is present and we partake of
him. The church has always believed
this.
This is again where they radically
reform so far they've completely lost
the plot.
It's like I'll bring this up with
Adventists. I I'll get into talking
about real presence. They'll say,
"You're Roman Catholic, dude. It's
universal. What are you talking about?"
They argued around mechanics. They
weren't saying, "Well, he's not present
at all."
Which is what the SDA church claims.
This is central in the understanding
that the church has had for 2,000 years
regarding grace.
The act of the Eucharist is an actual
means of grace whereby God alone grows a
person in holiness because we actually
receive Christ and his benefits in the
Eucharist. And the irony of this and the
reason they have to reject this, well,
there's a number of reasons, but the
irony of it is that Calvin's view of
growth in in Christ strikes a straight
blow to your guys' investigative
judgment. Notice
great controversy. Remember folks,
selected messages book 3
122.2
page 122 selected messages book three
paragraph 2 great controversy barricaded
by a thus saith the Lord.
quote, "Attended by heavenly angels, our
great high priest enters the Holy of
Holies and there appears in the presence
of God to engage in the last acts of
administration in behalf of man to
perform the work of investigative
judgment and to make atonement for all
who were shown to be entitled to its
benefits."
Close quote. Major major problem here,
folks. For one, Calvin didn't believe
the atonement was still going on.
But the reception of Christ's benefits
in Adventism is dependent upon the
investigative judgment where Jesus is
examining to see who's actually worthy
of his benefits. You don't receive them
in the sacraments like Lutherans,
Presbyterians, and Waldenzians and
Hussites all believe. You guys don't.
Again, demonstrating churches of the
Reformation have far more unity than
Adventism who tries to cherrypick from
all over and then claim they're the
fullness of light restored. a bastion of
total unity with no division and
confusion like all those Protestants
over there.
So the John Calvin link is badly busted.
Just like Luther, all branches of the
Reformation teach and believe that you
receive Christ and his benefits in the
sacraments, not in Adventism. It's after
you've you're found worthy through the
investigative judgment, then you can
receive the benefits of Christ.
Don't give me this nonsense. You guys
are not attached to them at all, sir.
John Robinson understood this principle.
He was the pastor to the Puritan
pilgrims who sailed the Mayflower to the
new world to this very country in which
we are privileged to live.
Unable to make the journey himself, he
admonished them or instructed them as
follows. If God should reveal anything
to you by any other instrument of his,
be as ready to receive it as ever you
were to receive any truth of my
ministry.
For I am very confident, the Lord hath
more truth and light yet to break forth
out of his holy word. So God was leading
a church over a period of centuries
until further truth would be restored by
a final body of believers at the end
time.
I'll tell you right now, I think that's
where we are. The end time. This
movement would be built on the shoulders
of the reformers, but it would go way
beyond the reformers and restore the
entire truth lost sight of by a
compromised church.
Yeah.
John Robin Robinson and and end times
people.
So God was leading a church through the
centuries until further truth would be
restored by a final body of believers at
the end of time. Ted, that is not what
John Robinson, that's not what he was
saying.
Once again, we have a partial truth with
great controversy details being tacked
on to try and spin it. The this quote is
from the book The Words of John
Robinson. I have it. It's specifically
from his farewell address to the
pilgrims upon the departure from Holland
in 1620. So, I went and looked it up to
see what was going on in this quote. And
while Ted is correct that Robinson had
the mindset that the reformers didn't go
far enough and further understanding
would come over time as the church
continued to study, he did not believe
this was leading to an end times people
who would be an amalgamation of various
individuals down through the centuries
that would then be God's last day
church. But even if he were saying that,
Ted, he says specifically, "This will
come from scripture, not a prophetist
who's an infallible interpreter to give
you all sorts of extra details not found
in the Bible." Because, see, that's the
thing, folks. They want to tell you all
our doctrines are just biblical. We're
the, you know, bastion of unity amongst
all the division. We have the God
particle, the the the great controversy
theme, the the antidote to theological
division. Herbert Douglas tells us.
Yeah. all these extra details not found
in scripture that are just a plain thus
sayeth the Lord. Yet no, Robinson and
the Puritans also didn't believe in a
great apostasy right after the apostles
such that the church needed restored
like you guys claim. So when Robinson
says this, it it isn't in that mindset.
He's simply uh affirming the the the the
motto of uh seer reformanda
always the church should always be
reforming in accordance with scripture.
That doesn't mean the church completely
fell away and then we need to be
studying the Bible and then lead to some
cornucopia movement like Adventism.
Again though we heard the classic we
stand on the shoulders of the reformers
claim.
Yeah. They stand on the shoulders of the
reformers even though they look nothing
like the reformers. They stand on the
shoulders of the reformers, but if you
adhere to Lutheran theology or
Presbyterian theology, Anglican
theology, and you don't come to join the
Adventists, you'll be damned.
Him and Ty Gibson are right though when
they said that they've gone way beyond
the reformers. Notice they both said
that
because again, they far more closely
resemble the radical reformation, the
Anabaptists.
That's not continuing the reformation,
folks. Resurrecting a bunch of ancient
heresies and adopting them is not
continuing to reform. That's called
resurrecting ancient heresies and
adopting them.
But just a reminder, folks, back from
when we looked at John Lomang, who also
tried to make this claim, remember
10 ways, or rather 11. I I'll say 10
because there's one that could be a
maybe.
Notice the the parallel in comparison
here. Classical Protestantism, which is
what reformation theology is, over and
against official Adventist theology.
Classical Protestants, the reformed,
reformers, I should say. The reformed is
specifically the Presbyterian branch,
but all the branches are monists.
Adventists are synergists. Protestants
affirm solos scriptora which is the sole
infallible rule of faith. Meaning
there's only one infallible source over
and against the SDA concept which is
essentially new to scriptor completely
denuting scripture from history. But
then they have Ellen White's writings as
another infallible source to give them
the infallible interpretation. Plus the
Holy Spirit is supposedly divinely
leading the GC in session.
So you really have three sources of
infallible authority in Adventism. Not
one. The law gospel distinction. They
have no law gospel distinction. The the
reformed or or Protestants affirm
visible invisible church distinction.
Adventists teach they're the end times
remnant. There's ministry of word and
sacrament amongst all Protestants. They
have no ministry of word and sacrament.
We have church discipline. They have
dysfellowshipping. That's the one that
okay, we'll give them that one.
Protestants reformed the reformation
theology affirms infant baptism. They
reject infant baptism. We're creedle
apostles nyene athanation. They're
anti-redle. We believe in a finished
atonement. They have an unfinished
atonement. The the Protestants affirm no
modern prophets. They affirm modern
prophets. We believe the Lord's day is
the first day because we understand the
new creation. They believe the Lord's
day is the seventh day and they're stuck
in the old creation.
Literally all of the hallmarks of
Protestantism, the SDA church is out of
step with except maybe church
discipline. So every hallmark of
Protestantism was wrong according to
them. We only needed the Reformation for
the pet doctrines the SDA churches
cherrypicked.
But yeah, sure. They're totally heirs of
the Reformation, right, Ted?
Ted, you are kidding yourselves if you
think you guys are theologically
bulletproof.
The idea that they are the bastion of
truth amidst everyone else who's
doctrinally confused and compromised has
got to be one of the biggest instances
of projection.
Adventism is a total mess of varying
viewpoints on all sorts of stuff. You
have anti-trinitarians in your ranks.
You have people who reject the
investigative judgment. You have people
that reject the Sunday law. People that
reject the health message. Yet in your
system, all of these things are
foundational.
You remove you remove the health message
for example. Then you have to deal with
okay well what about all the stuff that
Ellen said. Ellen in the fundamental
belief number 18 is the identifying mark
of the remnant church. So was she wrong?
Well then she doesn't meet the biblical
standard now. Well now you have to
remove that. That's the keystone of the
arch. All this stuff is foundational
folks. They'll try to point to to
Presbyterians for example. Well see you
you guys have stuff you disagree on,
right? But we're not in the same boat
you guys are in. We're united on the
fundamentals. We recognize that not
everything is essential, but in
Adventism, it's all essential. It's all
the gospel supposedly.
The conservative SDAs called, you know,
call the the people who reject these
things infiltrators from the world that
Satan has planted there, evil angels
masquerading as, you know, Adventists.
Then the liberals call the conservatives
out of touch with modernity. And then
they bicker amongst themselves as to
what Adventism even is. You guys are one
of the most divided groups I've ever
come across. And I've done a lot of
apologetics.
This is Ted reiterating the claim of
Herbert Douglas that the SDA church has
the God particle, the great controversy
theme, which is supposed to be the
antidote to theological division.
Remember, they didn't discover it. It
was given to them. They're kidding
themselves.
And they don't even put John Robinson in
their chain. He's just mentioned for who
even knows what. Who cares what he said?
How does this quote support this whole
narrative? It doesn't. It's just another
stolen quote to try and push the
narrative forward, which is why this was
his launching off point where Ellen now
begins to turn into focusing on the
SDAs.
Do you know
that Martin Luther still believed
in sprinkling babies?
Infant baptism. It's contrary to the
Bible, but it was part of Luther's
creed.
So, my friends, do you find sprinkling
babies in the Bible?
No.
Hey, Ted, you know what else you don't
find in the Bible?
Women taking communion.
So, therefore, I guess women shouldn't
take communion, right?
That's the standard.
Just give me one example, Ted, of a
woman taking communion in scripture.
We'll wait.
This is just a variation of the verbatim
fallacy.
Since there's not a verbatim text that
says baptize infants or an example of it
happening, that means it has to be
unbiblical.
Again, tell me you don't understand what
people believe without telling me you
don't understand what people believe.
Yeah, it was in it's in the Augsburg
confession. It's in the Westminster
Confession of Faith, etc. uh because
there's a scriptural argument.
Deal with it.
But be consistent then and don't
administer communion to women because
there's no example of it in the Bible.
While you're at it, you're going to need
to throw out Ellen White because her
name's not found in the Bible. The
investigative judgment, the health
message, national Sunday law, the great
controversy, and virtually all of your
guys' theology because none of that is
verbatim in the text.
This is a ridiculous standard and shows
you don't even understand why the
reformed churches baptize infants.
Now, I don't want to spend a huge chunk
of time on this. This isn't typically
like a hobby horse that I ride. This is
an area where again there are
Protestants, and I I'm using the term
more loosely there, not classical
Protestants, but modern evangelicals
that disagree. That's fine. But because
he brought this up, whether you agree or
disagree, not really my point here, but
sharing is caring. Okay, I'm going to
explain why the reformed, which is the
Presbyterian branch, affirms infant
baptism. It is because of covenant
theology.
We argue that there are only two
fundamental covenants throughout
redemptive history. The covenant of
works, which is law, and the covenant of
grace, which is gospel.
At different points in redemptive
history, those covenants have been
administered. So you've got the
Abrahamic, the Mosaic, the Davidic, etc.
The covenant that God made with Adam was
an administration of the covenant of
works. Do this and you'll live. Do that
and you'll die.
That the initial covenant that God made
with Adam, those were the conditions.
There was no grace mentioned.
Do this, you'll live. Do that and you'll
die. Adam broke this covenant. However,
God was gracious in administering the
covenant of grace by foretelling them of
the gospel in Genesis 3:15. God didn't
kill them on the spot. Instead, he
killed a substitute in their place and
clothed them in the garments of that
substitute, which is a picture of Jesus
dying for his people, clothing them in
his garments, his righteousness.
We then have various administrations of
the covenant of grace throughout history
leading to the new covenant which is
what all of it's pointing to.
Specifically though, excuse me, in the
administration with Abraham, God
commanded Abraham to administer the sign
of the covenant to himself and his
children.
That sign was circumcision.
The Abrahamic covenant was an
administration of the covenant of grace.
How do we know this? Well, there's a
number of reasons, but one, when Paul
wants to point to an example for the new
covenant gospel of grace, what does he
point to in Romans 4?
Abraham.
And he applies it to new covenant
Christians. Abraham was not saved some
other way. Back then they were saved
this way and then at this point saved to
this way. No. All people will be in
eternity for the same reasons.
saved the same way. Abraham believed
God. It was credited to him as
righteousness. We can read then in
Genesis 15 where God cuts the covenant
with Abraham and Abraham is put to
sleep. God being the one that then
passes through the cut animal and then
Abraham is essentially just a recipient.
He's not even an active participant.
God passing through that cut animal was
him saying, "If I break covenant with
you, let me be like this animal."
Abraham didn't pass through. He was a
passive recipient. It was all of God.
God alone.
He was basically demonstrating that
he'll never break covenant with his
people in the covenant of grace. But in
this administration of the covenant of
grace, we see that the sign of it was
commanded to be administered to
believers and their children.
This same thing carried over into the
Mosaic covenant, for example, all the
way through to the new covenant.
circumcision carried over into the
Mosaic, but the sign of the Mosaic was
the seventh day Sabbath, but it still
was being applied believer and their
children. That's the point. However, in
the new covenant, which is an
administration of the covenant of grace,
the new covenant form of the sign of the
covenant is baptism, not circumcision.
The old forms of Passover, circumcision,
and seventh day Sabbath take on new
covenant forms of the Lord's supper,
baptism, and the first day Sabbath. So
in Colossians 2 11-12, Paul says that
when a person is baptized, the same
thing that was done in circumcision is
done to a person in the new covenant.
That was his argument to say, you don't
have to be circumcised because what was
done to you in circumcision was done to
you in your baptism.
which is where the parallel is being
made between circumcision and baptism.
So our argument is that since God has
not said that the sign of the covenant
of grace is to no longer be applied to
believers children, we see no reason to
stop.
The covenant sign in the covenant of
grace is still to be applied to them.
It gets a little bit well it gets a lot
more detailed than that but for the sake
of time that's the position of the
reformed in a nutshell. Lutheran are a
little bit different but substantively
they're the same. We don't need verbatim
wording or an example to have a biblical
basis just like you don't need an
example and verbatim wording to be able
to use logic deduction reason etc to
deduce that very clearly women are also
to take communion.
The argument really comes down to
hermeneutics and who's handling the
Bible consistently. In one place the SDA
church will use the verbatim argument
like with the Sabbath. Show me one verse
in the Bible that says Sunday's the day
of worship type stuff. But if you then
apply that standard to their own system
as a whole, you have to give up 90% of
the doctrines because they're not
verbatim found in the Bible.
Investigative judgment gone. Ellen White
gone. National turn to international
Sunday law gone. Pope is the Antichrist
gone. American Revelation gone. You get
the point.
So, I'm sorry, Ted, but you don't know
or understand what you criticize. And
once again, unjust weights and measures.
That's not in the Bible. It took the
Baptists or the Anabaptist movement
to understand Christ's words about
baptism. Matthew 28:es 19 and 20. Go
therefore and make disciples of all the
nations, baptizing them in the name of
the Father and of the Son and of the
Holy Spirit, teaching them to observe
all things that I have commanded you.
Not only baptize them, but teach them to
observe. And lo, I am with you always,
even to the end of the age. Amen.
Ah, yes. the Anabaptists who were a
counterreformation move.
The SDA church is an heir of the
Reformation, but also the Anabaptists. I
mean, seriously,
there's so many other areas of
Anabaptist theology that the SDA church
doesn't align with. And yet, theology is
connected to other parts of the system.
Each individual doctrine doesn't stand
alone in isolation such that you can
just come along and pluck one from here
and there, etc.
The SDA church didn't just get adult
believers baptism from the Anabaptists.
They also got their radical new church
theology which it was a precursor for
this these restorationist movements.
Again, notice Dr. Sha's history of the
Christian church volume 8.
Now, he's talking here about the Swiss
Reformation and uh Hri Ols Wingley's uh
contention and and confrontation with
the Anabaptists.
Notice quote having cons having
considered Zwingley's controversy with
Romanism we must now review his conflict
with radicalism which ran parallel with
the former and exhibits the conservative
and churchly side of his reformation.
Radicalism was identical with the
Anabaptist movement but the baptismal
question was secondary.
It involved an entire reconstruction of
the church and of the social order. It
meant revolution. The Romanist pointed
triumphantly to revolution as the
legitimate and inevitable result of the
Reformation, but history has proved the
difference. Close quote.
And sadly, that's exactly what still
happens despite the facts. Rome points
to sex like the SDAs, who are in harmony
with the radicalists, not the reformers,
to say, "See, that's the inevitable
result. Look, that's what Protestantism
produces." when no, these people are
untethered rogue agents with no
connection to the church in history.
Nevertheless, baptism was a secondary
issue with the Anabaptist Ted. It was
the fruit of deeper issues. The name
Anabaptist means rebaptizer and it was
people who renounced their infant
baptisms and got rebaptized as adults.
They contended with with Zwingley
because they didn't want a reformation
of the church state at all.
Instead, they wanted a reinstitution of
the true church, which they thought they
possessed. Ah, who's that sound like?
It's exactly what Adventism resembles
with stuff like the idea of the church
going apostate, needing to be restored,
and that they're the remnant with the
fullness of the truth, yada yada. The
fact that you even classify the
Anabaptist with Luther and John Calvin
as reformers in this chain says it all.
The Anabaptists didn't affirm word and
sacraments as a means of grace. Ah,
who's that sound like, which was part of
their conflict with the reformers. Yet
the SDA church is claiming to be in line
with Luther on grace and the Anabaptist
on on baptism.
Baptism is one of the sacraments. Ted,
notice R. Scott Clark, professor of
church history and historian.
Quote,
"The recovery of the ancient Christian
doctrine and practice of the sacraments
was so essential to the reformation that
the reformed churches in Europe and the
British Isles spoke of the right use of
the sacraments as marks of the true
church." In article 29 of the Belgic
Confession, the French and
Dutch-speaking churches confess that
there are three marks of a true church.
The pure preaching of the gospel, the
pure administration of the sacraments,
and the use of church discipline. The
phrase pure administration of the
sacraments was a shorthand way of
rejecting both the Anabaptists and Rome.
Close quote.
The the reformers would staunchly reject
you guys as well as the same for the
same reason and a host of others.
Another area where you guys have
reformed so far you don't even agree
with one of the essential tenants of the
reformation word and sacrament ministry.
You guys are not on the shoulders of the
reformers sir. you were in the loins of
the Anabaptists, which explains why
Adventism is such a confused theological
mess. But then he cites the great
commission. Ted, we agree. We agree. The
irony of this is that children of
believers meet the qualification of the
great commission.
They're in the world and as Christian
parents, we disciple them and teach them
to obey what Jesus commanded. I was just
catechizing my son earlier. That's what
that is.
Literally the only aspect of that that
you have a problem with is baptizing
them. Yet nothing in the great
commission disqualifies them from
baptism.
In fact, whenever we have an infant
baptism at my church, like last week, my
pastor cites this exact paricopy amongst
a number of others.
What's funny about you citing this
though, Ted, is that you guys aren't
fulfilling the great commission. You
guys are on a different mission with a
different message sent out by a
different Jesus, with a different
spirit.
The true Christ said, "Lo, I am with you
always. I himself," not the Holy Spirit
as his representative in his physical
absence.
The Adventist Jesus, folks, isn't always
with you because he isn't omnipresent.
He gave that up upon incarnating. Notice
what the Adventist believe 28
fundamental beliefs book says. This is
the exposition of their own fundamental
beliefs.
Quote, Jesus asserted his omnipresence
with the assurance, lo, I am with you
always, even to the end of the age. And
where two or three are gathered together
in my name, I am there in the midst of
them. Although his divinity has the
natural ability of omnipresence, the
incarnate Christ has voluntarily limited
himself in this respect. He has chosen
to be omnipresent through the ministry
of the Holy Spirit. Close quote.
The exact verse that Ted read, the
Advenist Jesus has voluntarily limited
himself regarding his omnipresence and
is only omnipresent through the Holy
Spirit. Despite Hebrews 13 saying that
Jesus is immutable,
which the book in the literal next
paragraph, the Adventist believe book,
the literal next paragraph goes on to
assert.
They literally go on to assert
Hebrews 13 like hello
limiting his omnipresence upon
incarnating means Jesus isn't the same
today, yesterday, and forever. It means
he isn't the fullness of the godhead
bodily, contrary to Colossians 2:9.
Apparently, the Adventist Jesus has the
ability to turn aspects of his nature
and being on and off.
So Ted, you guys don't even believe what
Jesus said, which is that he himself,
Jesus, not just the Holy Spirit, would
be with his people always, even to the
end of the age. The Holy Spirit and
Jesus are not the same person.
Then again, we had a video from Ted a
couple weeks ago that the SDA Church put
up on their YouTube page talking about
the Trinity. He goes on to describe
modalism.
Maybe that's the problem.
But this concept in your fundamental
beliefs book was formulated back in the
days when your pioneers didn't even
believe the Holy Spirit was a person.
But Jesus and the father's presence in
their physical absence. And since Ellen
gave the stamp of approval on it, you're
stuck having to uphold it. Furthermore,
Jesus didn't send the apostles out
preaching to believe the Adventist
system of theology for the forgiveness
of sins. Again, the SDA church equates
the gospel with systematic theology. The
Anabaptist link in the great controversy
chain is intact. Sure. But that doesn't
help support this narrative that the
Bible claims various movements would
rise up with one single thing correct
that was lost in history and then the
seventh adventist will be a cornucopia
of all of that in the last days which
are going to arbitrarily start in 1844.
God raised up another man by the name of
John Wesley.
Wesley saw that the standards of the
church were decaying. He saw that the
amusements, the pleasures of attraction
in the world and the practices were
entering into the church. And so God
raised up John Wesley
and showed him that when men and women
study the holy word of God that they
were to live righteous and holy lives by
God's grace.
I tell you I believe in holiness
not through my own power but through my
connection with Jesus. I believe that
the church should be separate from the
influences of the world. I believe that
if you are a Christian, you should look
like a Christian, eat like a Christian,
go places that Christians go to.
Claiming to be a Christian, but drinking
alcohol and indulging in worldly
entertainment and dress, trying to look
like the world is not true primitive
Christianity.
It's selfdeception.
So earlier Ted mentioned John Calvin and
growth in Christ which has to do with
holiness and holy living. He talked
about Luther and said they're in line
with him because one thing that he was
right about was his view of grace. Yet
now talking about John Wesley, he says
Wesley believed people ought to live
holy and righteous lives by God's grace.
Ted Luther and John Wesley didn't hold
to the same view of grace like we saw
John George Knight recognize earlier.
Nor did John Calvin and Wesley affirm
the same thing about growing in
holiness. So now you have conflicting
views in your chain due to borrowing
from various people but not realizing
what they meant by terms which is the
problem with latching on to Christian
ees like growth and grace.
But chained onto that we get the claim
that Christians will be tea totlers and
not engage in any worldly entertainment.
So now under the guise of John Wesley,
he's going to slip in the health message
and temperance doctrines of the SDA
church,
which are ultimately coming from Ellen
White like we looked at a couple weeks
ago. For example,
nowhere, folks, nowhere does the Bible
condemn alcohol.
It condemns drunkenness. Adventists love
Ecclesiastes 9:5 where they think
Solomon is giving an anatomy lesson. But
literally two verses later, two verses
later,
go eat your bread with joy and drink
your wine with a merry heart for God has
already approved what you do.
Solomon writing about enjoying your life
with your spouse, that's the context
here, says to enjoy the days and work
hard at what you do and don't let your
life be in vain. He's talking about life
under the sun. Go read the chapter.
Amidst that, he says to drink your wine
with a merry heart. Doesn't sound like
tea tolling, Ted. Psalm 104:14-15.
You caused the grass to grow for the
livestock and plants for man to
cultivate that we may bring forth food
from the earth and wine to gladden the
heart of man, oil to make his face
shine, and bread to strengthen man's
heart.
So the psalter said, "What?"
He's praising the wondrous works of the
true God and he explains the many things
that God brings about for the benefit of
man. One of which is the stuff to make
wine which gladdens the heart.
Furthermore,
the Lord's supper is actual wine, not
Welches. Adventists can try and spin the
new wine into old wines verse to try and
say it's talking about grape juice, but
this is silliness. The Greek word used
for the wedding at Kaa in John 2 is oos.
That's the Greek word oos. This is the
word for basic alcoholic wine. The same
word that Paul uses in Ephesians 5:18
where he says to not be drunk on it,
which means it's talking about alcoholic
wine. On top of that, in 1 Corinthians
11, Paul is chastising the Corinthians
for their abuse of the Eucharist and
says that some of them were getting
drunk on the wine. It wasn't grape
juice.
Welches was invented in 1869, folks.
Just simple facts.
Point being, no. The Bible does not
condemn alcohol consumption as
uncchristian.
It's ironically quite the opposite. The
supper is commanded and it's wine.
Ted has taken the Adventist standards in
their little subculture and then equates
that with being biblical and Christian
standards, demonstrating that Ellen
White is the standard, not scripture. He
says, "If you engage in these things,
you're self-deceived." Ted, what's your
definition of worldly entertainment?
Let's hear the objective standard for
what that is. This is the problem with
these legalistic cults. They all have
their own standard of this stuff. There
is zero level of nuance and context to
any given situation. like alcohol. It's
either you consume it, you're a sinner
and condemned, or you don't and you're
fine.
The idea that Adventists don't consume
any worldly entertainment is totally
laughable.
Remember at the beginning of this talk,
he started off by saying the Indy500 was
going on, but you chose to be here
instead. That's his little dig. And I
brought that up in that part as well.
That's his little dig at see real
followers of Jesus aren't going to be
out there at some worldly race. They're
going to be here getting indoctrinated
with Adventism.
That's worldly entertainment.
TED concerts are worldly entertainment.
Netflix is worldly entertainment.
Restaurants are worldly entertainment.
Amusement parks are worldly
entertainment. Yet, Adventists consume
all sorts of this stuff. It doesn't make
you worldly to go to a movie. Doesn't
make you worldly to take your kids to a
theme park. And this is precisely what
leads to all sorts of bickering amongst
SDAs, pointing the finger back and forth
on who's right and where the line is
drawn.
What Ted really means is more along the
lines of cult thinking. By worldly
entertainment, he means staying closed
in the permitted SDA bubble. They'll
tell you what is and isn't acceptable.
This is one area, folks, of their
movement that has got to be one of the
most subjective, especially
geographically.
It's like Ted, wine is strictly
forbidden and condemned. One of your
blue zones in Greece, one of the key in
one of the key things they consume is
wine.
He talked about eating like a Christian,
aka the health message. The Okinawa,
Japan Blue Zone. One of the key
ingredients in proteins is pork. It's
like, can you even make this stuff up?
Are you that lacking in self-awareness?
Oh, no. They're doctrinally perfect with
nothing to learn and and they're here to
teach the rest of us with their super
glow-in-the-dark level understanding.
They're they're so holy, folks. They
just glow in the dark.
They just can't get on the same page
about watching the Super Bowl. They just
can't agree on if if drinking Mountain
Dew is a sin.
Just such a joke, guys.
And any person who's come out of
Adventism, you know exactly what I'm
talking about. Such a joke. You're just
kidding yourselves. It's such a joke.
Like my whole life, I'm It's just a
constant subjectivity. It's just
hilarious that you would say something
like this with a straight face.
Let's be generous and say the John
Wesley chain is slightly damaged. They
basically took Wesley's idea of
Christian perfection and then by
filtering it through the great
controversy, they developed the
investigative judgment and needing to
arrive at a totally sinless state to
silence the accusations of Satan that uh
the ten commandments can't be kept.
Wesley didn't have a great controversy
worldview. He started to shift on his
view of perfection toward the end of his
life. Anyways, that's a whole can of
worms. But nevertheless, Wesley's idea
was not uh the same as what they say
with the great controversy.
There was another
thing that was lost sight of that needed
to be restored. And Pastor Finley
preached that with such power this
morning. The truth of the second coming
of Jesus Christ. God raised up a
powerful preacher in the 19th century
named William Miller. He was actually a
farmer and he had a struggle to actually
get to the point to proclaim what he was
studying personally and privately. But
God called him because God had a message
to speak through him to proclaim the
truth of the second coming of our Lord.
And at this time
the church had largely neglected the
second coming of Jesus. God raised up a
whole new movement called the
Adventists.
People who looked to the advent, the
coming of Jesus.
Do you believe that Jesus is coming
soon?
I believe that, too. So, I'm an
Adventist. All right.
Did you notice his switcheroo there?
He said the Adventists were a movement
that God raised up who were looking to
the advent, the second coming. Then
asks, "Do you believe that Jesus is
coming soon?"
Looking forward to the second coming has
nothing to do with Adventism.
Adventism has to do with imminency.
that the second coming could happen at
any minute.
Which is rather ironic because Ted is on
record saying that the apocalyptic hard
end times warnings in Ellen White's
writings such as the death decree to
kill Adventists for the Sabbath, the
Sunday law, etc. are not conditional
prophecies, meaning they will come about
for certain.
Yet, the second coming is imminent. It
could happen at any moment supposedly.
Like, which one is it, y'all?
There's no Sunday law or death decree
yet. make up your mind.
But then he said, "There's one thing
that was that was lost sight of and
needed restored. The second coming
a few weeks ago, we posted a video
responding to or or examining a claim
made by Walter Vice, who shilled out the
same line.
SDAs were coming for my throat over it.
I misrepresented him. I took him out of
context. I have no clue what he's
talking about. I'm an idiot." All the
same tired excuses. Yet here we have Ted
Wilson claiming the exact same thing
that Walter said, which is that in the
1840s when the Christian church rejected
the fanaticism of Millerism, they
supposedly rejected the second coming.
This truth was supposedly lost over time
and Miller restored that which is why
they try and rebrand him as a reformer.
Ted, this is so demonstrably false it's
almost hard to even take seriously.
Miller repopularized
imminency,
not the second coming outright. It is so
ridiculous when you guys say this.
No one forgot about the second coming,
Ted. The Apostles Creed is 1600 years
old, recited by lurggical worship
services all around the globe weekly in
households daily.
What does the second stanza say,
Christian?
What does the second stanza of the
Apostles Creed say? That Jesus is
returning to judge the living and the
dead? I had an Adventist try and argue
with me in the comments of that video.
I I doubt the majority of Christians
would even know the Apostles Creed.
All right. All the churches of the
Reformation affirm the Apostles Creed,
folks. The Roman Catholic Church, the
Eastern Churches, the Oriental Orthodox,
the Coptics, all Eastern churches, and
on and on. literally billions of people
through the centuries.
In fact, Rome, the Roman Catholic
Catechism, which far predates Millerism
states that the second coming is
imminent. We looked at that in that
video. It's like paragraph 640
or something like six, I think, in the
600s. The idea that the second coming
needed to be restored by a false prophet
in the 19th century is cope. You're
coping. You're trying to salvage the
rubble. With regards to William Miller
being a reformer, notice how he's
getting linked to all of this. Now,
William Miller, he has no connection
backward. He's a random farmer war
veteran that took a King James Bible and
a concordance and started doing all
sorts of ridiculous math, turning
passages that have nothing to do with
prophecy into prophetic time periods and
so on.
He was a false prophet that wrongfully
set a date for the return of Christ,
which scripture strictly forbids, and
then recanted after he was wrong twice.
He retained his belief that the second
coming was imminent. But he repented of
his false dates setting, and God bless
him for doing that. But because Ellen
and the gang, who are the theological
offspring of Miller,
they have to rebrand him in a more
positive light because to get rid of him
is to get rid of them.
So that's what we just heard. There's a
a book, by the way, folks, D by Donald
Casebolt. It's called Farmer Miller's
Daughter. Highly recommend it for those
of you that are really into former
Adventist books and literature. No one
else has really done a book like he did.
And it's really one of the uh like
unspoken ones. Donald Casebolt, Farmer
Miller's daughter. That's exactly what
this is about.
And what's fascinating about all this is
that Miller never came around to their
continued persistence. Miller never
became a Seventh Day Adventist.
Heck, he was part of the people that
Ellen White claimed in the path vision,
took his eyes off Christ, fell off the
path into the wicked world that God had
rejected because after 1844, he gave it
up like the majority did. So by Ellen's
standard, he was condemned.
She can't use the excuse, well, but
these previous generations, before we
were around, they were just in
ignorance.
Miller's in your chain, but he's
condemned.
Reformers were individuals that were
actually part of the church universal
and sought to bring change from within,
not rogue agents in the 19th century
that rose up with a Bible and just
started doing who even knows what and
claiming they now knew when the return
of Christ was.
By the SDA church's standard, all sorts
of individuals and false prophets be
would be considered reformers,
reformers of the Christian church.
Joseph Smith, Charles Russell, Anne Lee,
Mary Baker, Eddie, and on and on. All
individuals that the SDA church would
theologically stand in opposition to.
That's an interesting parallel there,
Ted. What about what about the the
similarities you guys have with the
Jehovah's Witnesses?
Why aren't they in that in in your
chain, Ted? Why can't we point to them
and say, "Well, you got this one thing
here. They should be in your chain, too,
right?" Oh, no, no, that's those nasty
first day sabotarians.
Or not first day sabotarian, sorry,
first day Adventists. If you want a fun
little uh experiment, folks, go into the
uh EG White online library, do a keyword
search on those uh first day Adventists
and look at some of the stuff she had to
say about him. But point being, no, God
was not speaking through a false
prophet. Ted Miller didn't restore
anything. He repopularized the belief in
imminency at a time where that was not a
dominant view. God did not raise up a
whole new movement aka a sect to then uh
give birth to another false prophet
which supposedly you know is the prophet
and identifying mark of God's last day
people. William Miller's link is
obviously intact though as yes they
quite literally go back to William
Miller. That's really as far back as the
chain goes a farmer in the 19th century.
But there was one more important
biblical truth that was not yet d uh
restored at this time. The truth that
faith leads to obedience
to the commandments of God and the
special truth regarding the seventh day
Sabbath as the symbol of Christ's
creative authority.
Christ would raise up a lastday
movement that would finally restore the
truth about God's ten commandments in a
time of commandment breaking. A last day
movement that would take seriously God's
instructions through Jesus Christ,
the living word as he pointed us to the
written word.
John 14 and verse 15, Jesus himself
says, "If you love me, keep my
commandments."
Jesus would have a last day movement in
the last days of earth's history where I
have just told you I believe that's
where we are. It would be outlined in
the book of Revelation. God would call
all humanity all over this globe back to
worship him who made heaven and earth
the sea and springs of water to worship
God in a pure way turning people back to
the true worship of God. God would call
all of us back to the truths of the
Bible.
SDA's restored the idea of believing the
commandments. Again, what a joke. The
Roman Catholic Church, the Eastern
Church, classical Protestants all
disagree with you, Ted. Clearly, you
have not looked at other people's
beliefs. This is just a pariting out of
Ellen White's assertions and taking it
as fact.
And just like that, now the SDAs are
linked to this chain supposedly. They're
the final end product, the apple of
God's eye. So all of that was leading to
this. That's all the details filling in
the gaps of that intro clip of Ty
Gibson. You know, the four steps,
apostolic to deformationation,
reformationation to restoration.
He said the Sabbath is the symbol of
Christ's creation authority. Well, hold
up there, bucko. Earlier with infant
baptism, he wanted a verbatim or literal
example, and it could or it couldn't be
biblical. Ted, nowhere does the Bible
say the Sabbath is a symbol of Christ's
creative authority. You guys use
deduction, inference, etc. to try and
deduce that from the text, just like the
reformed and Lutheran do with infant
baptism. You guys point to the Ten
Commandments and say, "Well, Exodus 20
roots it in creation, and it's the only
command that mentions the name, title,
and authority of the creator. So
therefore, but it doesn't say what you
claimed. That's a deduction on your
guys's part. Again, unjust weights and
measures abound. He said they were
raised up as a movement that would take
God's commands seriously in a time of
commandment breaking. Once again, Ted,
you're kidding yourselves.
You guys have a false god that's not
real, which violates all four of the
first commandments. You have an idol.
You make depictions of your idol, Jesus.
You've done so on your screen. You've
literally shown second commandment
violations in your presentation.
You uphold a false prophet that violated
the third commandment by bearing God's
name falsely repeatedly binding people's
conscience to her precepts.
And you don't keep the Sabbath because
in order to truly keep the Sabbath, you
have to know the true Christ who is the
substance of the Sabbath. That comes by
having the correct gospel
resting in the person and work of
Christ. Until you do that, it doesn't
matter what day you keep. You're lost. A
day will do you zero good.
Just like it did Israel zero good when
they perished in the wilderness by
hardening their hearts and not believing
the gospel. Hebrews 4 1-11.
This movement bears false witness
against Christians constantly.
It's hardwired into the system because
Ellen White's writings are supposedly
divine, which means she attributed her
bearing false witness and the bearing of
God's name falsely to God himself.
Furthermore, Adventists violate Jesus's
command in John 7 to not judge based on
appearances more than anyone else I've
ever encountered. It happens to me
multiple times a week on this platform.
They say something to the effect of,
"You have tattoos. You don't follow
Jesus." I've only heard this like five
million times. Like, good one. Oh, yeah.
Good one.
But Ted wants to assure us that
Adventists are a people that really
really seriously take the commands of
Jes, you know, take the the commands of
Jesus really, really seriously. What a
joke. What a joke. It wouldn't be an SDA
presentation if John 14:15 wasn't proof
texted. Again, context drives
interpretation. John 14:15 isn't talking
about the Ten Commandments, Ted. And
recognizing this doesn't mean that you
don't think the Ten Commandment or that
you think the Ten Commandments are
invalid for any purpose.
We've addressed this I don't even know
how many times. This is again where they
they launch off into a a the false
dichotomy fallacy, false dilemma
fallacy. Oh, so if it's not talking
about the Ten Commandments, that means
you think the Ten Commandments have no
use. No, it just means that specific
paricopy is not talking about the Ten
Commandments and it shows you don't know
how to rightly handle the Bible. You
don't use the HGM.
But again, Ted is kidding himself. And
and maybe this is evidence, Ted, that
you've been consuming worldly
entertainment and you because you sound
self-deceived.
So he later on in this talk, folks,
there's like four minutes left. Well,
then they they do a baptism of a person,
but he goes on to talk about how young
earth creationism is supposedly in
Revelation 14. Yes, young earth
creationism is now supposedly a part of
the gospel. If you don't believe if you
don't believe in young earth
creationism, you have a false god
according to them.
So apparently the apostles were
preaching believe young earth
creationism for the forgiveness of sins.
He also goes on to site uh just all the
favorite SDA proof texts that they use
to say the spirit of prophecies the
testimony of Jesus testimony of Jesus is
wherever Jesus is speaking. So since
he's speaking through Ellen White that
means they have the identifying mark the
remnant church yada yada. We've
addressed all this stuff on our website
as well as in video something that we
will continue to do. um into the future.
But what we heard here, folks to wrap it
up, what we heard here was Uncle Ted's
story hour, not preaching, not a history
lesson.
He paced around back and forth on the
stage with a Bible in his hand, but
engaged in zero biblical exposition.
Zero.
There was zero walking through the
biblical text verse by verse bringing
out the author's intended meaning and
then making present- day application.
None.
But they only believe a thus sayeth the
Lord.
Instead, what we got was more of him
giving a cliffnotes of the great
controversy and then the sprinkling in
of random verses from all over the Bible
playing hopscotch exesus
to say that those verses support what's
being said because that's what Ellen and
the SDA pioneers claim they mean. So, he
believes it.
They have to have this reframing of
history because it's how they get they
get written into the story. If there was
no great apostasy in the first century
such that the church needed to be
restored, this whole thing collapses.
And the ironic thing about this is that
the SDA church is a part of the actual
great apostasy,
the great falling away from the
teachings of Jesus being led after a
different Jesus and a different gospel.
They're a part of the great apostasy in
the last days. They're not the remedy to
it.
The great controversy is fiction. It's
not actual history.
Ted kept telling us in the previous look
at this talk that if it isn't a plain
thus sayith the Lord needs to be
rejected and then this last clip ended
by him saying God is calling all people
back to the truths of the Bible. Ted, I
agree.
And to do that, you're going to have to
abandon your entire pre-earth origin
story
which isn't found in the Bible. Your
entire foundation is going to have to be
scrapped which foils your whole
movement.
Let's hear book chapter and verse or
verse is for the claim that God is
vindicating his character by silencing
the accusations of Satan that started
before the creation of the earth that
Lucifer accused God's law of being
unjust and unfair and that it couldn't
be kept by a fallen sinner which that's
what then led to war breaking out in
heaven and Lucifer falling and becoming
Satan. Let's hear where Jesus offered a
plan to the father three times which he
finally accepted which entailed that
through the merits of Christ and a
person's obedience to the law they too
can silence Satan and vindicate God's
character demonstrating that they're
worthy of the atoning benefits of
Christ's sacrifice.
You guys believe a mountain of extra
biblical doctrines that you call a plain
thus sayeth the Lord because the line
between the Bible and Ellen White's
writings are so blurred that you can't
even tell where one stops and the other
starts.
You guys don't know the gospel. You have
a false Christ. And our hope is that God
continues to use this platform to be a
thorn in the minds of many Adventists,
provoking them to jealousy like Paul
hoped for regarding the Jews with the
Gentiles
such that they come taste and see that
the Lord is good, the true God and the
true gospel, not the Adventist idol who
ultimately needs saved by you, the
creature, from accusations of another
creature, Satan.
Now, I know I got a little bit worked up
tonight. That's tends to be a a thing
around here and I say it regularly.
We're not doing the kid gloves thing
over here. There are people that need
communicated to this way. I'm that way.
Um I wish somebody would have said just
shot it to me straight hard bare bones
truth. When I was in SDA,
there's a time and a place for that.
Folks, I'm not like this 247. I get into
this all the time. You You just seem
like a real miserable person. I'm not
like this all the time. You think I'm
always this?
No. Like, not at all. But this is
serious. This is not a game. This is not
a joke. We're not playing around here,
folks. I'm not going to go into to
things on our road map because they're
not guaranteed. And I don't like I I
can't stand when when like organizations
do that. They like put something out
there and get people all hyped up and
then it like fizzles or never comes
about and then people are like, "Hey,
whatever happened to that?" So, I don't
want to do that sort of thing. But let
me tell you this.
If our roadmap comes to fruition,
there's going to be uh
I long for the day, folks, that this
platform doesn't need to exist. I would
love to shut the lights down and go
start something else.
But as long as this organization exists,
this platform is going to exist. So that
should tell you what I mean when I say I
want this thing to shut down.
That's our roadmap to not even have to
do Answering Adventism anymore, to shut
the channel down, to shut YouTube down.
It could be a historical reference
source for people in the future to look
back and say, "Oh yeah, look at this
sect that lasted however long and what
have you." That's the mission. Make this
enemy be a foottool under the feet of
Jesus to move along while more enemies
are are made a foottool. when we can go
out and do apologetics to some other
sect and cult that rises up.
But yeah, when we're dealing with stuff
like this, it has to be stated firmly,
seriously. And I don't like deception. I
don't like people being uh
misrepresented. You know, SDAs will say
that about our platform. You constantly
misrepresent. Yeah, except I'm using
primary source documentation. Refute the
source documentation, crickets.
Yet you guys will just make assertions
about people like the Waldenzians that
are outright lies,
verifiably so, and you'll continue
pariting it, and then add an appendix
into the into your book to try and cover
up for your false prophet.
So yeah, I'm going to be harsh with a
person like that. I'm going to be firm
with a person like that. It's rude. and
to talk about these people as if they're
some extinct people.
Thank you for being here. Hopefully this
was beneficial for you. Study actual
church history, friends. That's the
lesson. That way you don't get taken for
a ride by these ridiculous things like
the great controversy where if you don't
know anything about these things, you
can hear a presentation like this and
think, "Oh, wow. Oh, folks, if you know
actual church history, you can pick
apart what Ted was doing here.
I mean,
these SDA pioneers, man, the people that
systematized this theology, they
couldn't exute their way out of a wet
paper bag.
Study actual church history. Yes, it's
messy. No, humans are not perfect. But
it is a lot more rich than this very
narrow, caricatured, carefully crafted
retelling of it. Adventism was born out
of a false prophecy from a false prophet
that only begot more of the same mess.
They refused to accept that they were
wrong and they still refuse. And that's
just the barebone facts.
This movement has their own mission,
excuse me, their own mission, their own
message, their own God, all of which
stand in contradistinction to the
Christian church's message, mission, and
God. Do not be fooled. We have to take
the great commission or fulfill the
great commission by taking the true
Christ and his gospel to SDAs beating
down the gates of hell with the truth.
That's the goal here. Equip Christians
to reach Adventists to go into the
trenches, go into the fire on the
spiritual battlefield and go and take
the good news of the Lord Jesus Christ
to Adventist trusting that God will do
what God will do.
May the triune God richly bless you in
the grace and peace of the Lord Jesus
Christ. Trust in his perfect work,
friends, his vicarious death on the
cross for all of your sins.
[Music]